so it seems the biggest story today is
fake news they're claiming that the doj
informed Trump he would be indicted next
week and now that's being revised to say
that he's actually just the target of a
probe but we already knew that because
they literally raided the guy's house
over classified documents so it seems
maybe that CNN is just desperate
considering their CEO is gone now you
got Fox News threatening to sue Tucker
Carlson now you've got parents in the in
California fighting far left extremists
in the street over the grooming of their
kids that one really pissed off the left
when I tweeted about that but it really
does seem I guess like the actual
biggest story right now is the the air
quality and so
I gotta be honest it's probably the
least
I don't know how to describe it it's
it's not the most cultural story but it
probably is the most pressing to at
least talk about a little bit and so
we're going back and forth like do we
just talk about this ridiculous fake
indictment story or well we should
probably at least talk about the fact
that if you look outside and you're on
the East Coast everything's orange and
it's probably going to get worse so
we're in the DC area and it got pretty
bad and so everyone's basically talking
about everyone's a lot of questions so I
figure we can at least leave with that
and then talk about all the culture War
stuff so before we get started my
friends head over to castbrew.com and
purchase our coffee if you'd like to
support our work we are building a
parallel economy if you want to support
companies that don't hate you buy your
coffee from us we're going to be
building coffee shops we're going to be
producing more products and giving you
alternatives to the welcome corporate
ecosystem it's the only way we're gonna
win but also don't forget to go to go to
timcast.com click join us to become a
member and support our work directly as
a member you'll get access to our
members only uncensored show Monday
through Thursday at about 10 p.m we put
them up you can hang out even call into
the show and ask us questions so don't
forget to smash that like button
subscribe to this channel share this
show with your friends joining us
tonight to talk about this and a whole
lot more is John cardillo hey guys great
to be back with you man I was looking
forward to this absolutely who are you
what do you do who am I what am I do I'm
on Twitter I get yelled at a lot because
I went from Trump to DeSantis I used to
be a cop now I'm a boring private Equity
guy after being on air for a lot of
years and occasionally pop up here hang
out with you guys
thanks for hanging out nah it's awesome
man good to be back we got shames my
name is Seamus Cagle and I have a
YouTube channel called Freedom Tunes
where we upload cartoons every single
week so if you guys want to check that
out head over there we're releasing a
cartoon tomorrow that I think is going
to be really funny we're making fun of
uh kind of The Little Mermaid reboot and
all these different race swapped reboots
uh and I think you guys will enjoy it
and go to freedomtunes.com if you want
to help support us and you'll get an
extra cartoon each week that's only
available to members on the website Ian
Crossland here happy to see you guys my
nose is itching so let's get to this
search yeah yeah I feel you man it's
been like first of all the allergies bad
and on top of that all the smoke is not
making my life better anyways crazy
let's jump into this first story take a
look at this image from CNN millions in
U.S under air quality alerts as Canada
wildfires rage you know
we're mostly a political cultural and
news show but I think this story is so
pressing that uh we probably should at
least talk about it a little bit because
this this is going to directly impact
you and it directly impacts us the
concern that I have of course is uh for
the chickens because uh the the this
garbage falls on the ground yeah and
when we had the East Palestine thing
when they're saying all those chemicals
were blasting up into the air and
floating floating out of here chickens
were dying and so uh I'm being somewhat
Silly by referencing chickens but when
the when when this stuff settles and
gets all over the grass and gets all
over everything that's going to cause
problems too so basically there's
wildfires up in Canada
FAA has issued ground stops in New York
because the air quality was so bad you
couldn't actually see where we are in DC
apparently we're being told that it's
going to get worse tomorrow and it's
going to persist in New York and on the
East Coast until tomorrow as well so I
don't know how many of you guys are
experiencing this but you know this is
this is the latest we have this map here
record smog levels in Northeast and
right now you can see it's mostly bad in
the New York area it's going to come
down and heavily hit DC tomorrow so
apparently they're saying like where we
are it's gonna this guy's gonna turn
orange or something you know all the
talk we talk about war and chaos and
politics and stuff man it's these
natural disasters that can really
annihilate a civilization oh yeah this
is just a taste yeah I mean I flew in
through this today I landed in DC from
South Florida at about 2 30 p.m and I
was running around to get to the airport
this morning I had no idea I'm ashamed
to say I saw some things on Twitter
about Canada I really had no idea what
was going on until the Pilot mentioned
it I noticed we had it was pretty clear
I mean some clouds a little bit of bombs
but it's mostly clear and then this
weird Haze started but we weren't
hitting turbulence you know so when you
typically on approach you come through
the clouds you're bouncing a bit it was
dead smooth and the pilot came already
said oh if you notice you can't see the
ground it's this air from Canada I was
still I still had Wi-Fi and I checked it
out and I'm actually driving after I see
you guys said I'm gonna start heading to
New York for a family uh event and I
just I'd ping my nephew before we went
live and I said how's the air quality
said it's absolutely terrible like can't
see your hand in front of your face yo
check out this real bet just keep
talking about let me play this video
check this video out so the point I was
going to make is Ian I think you made a
very good point about the fact that
people don't consider natural disasters
uh and or at least enough especially as
modern people because we like to think
that we're in control of everything we
can solve all of our problems there's
nothing unforeseen that's going to knock
us over in what's strange is even when
we are confronted by natural disasters
like this people still want to try to
claim that we're in control of them this
happened because we're you know burning
too much uh CO2 or putting too much of
it out into the atmosphere here this is
a human invention if we only behaved
better and didn't make the weather so
angry this wouldn't occur like we can't
accept that some things are just out of
our control yeah that's a good point man
it's it's very freaky to say like we are
not in control of this life like at any
moment a meteor could strike and set the
world on fire again a global flood
something could knock out the sun like
block it block out the sun like this
kind of thing kill all the crops for
three to four years mass migrations and
I was gonna say suicides and you know
the politics of this is they're saying
it's climate change no exactly exactly
they're like this is climate change it's
happening now everyone quit it's all
man-made that's what I'm saying we have
to make it our fault we have to put
place it under our control but sorry you
were no no no I'm just gonna say I
disagree with you guys I I look I I
learned from the Democrats Al Gore
created fire in 2001. that's right it
created everything
it was a DARPA project he invented the
internet then he flinton's deal he
created fire and uh here we are now so
we should have listened so what is this
this I'm not this is a joke is this a
CIA op to go like fires in Canada to get
a false flag we have funny Oregon
Washington California have these
wildfires they're never called toxic
what the hell is in the Canadian
wilderness that's Landing orange
toxicity whatever it is for a long time
apparently yeah what is something wrong
that's why maple syrup trees are burning
and the air is moving down and
everyone's freaking out it was kind of
crazy I woke up and uh because where we
are you have you can see the mountains
yeah and there's like a white fog it's
like I hate right yeah yeah it's a haze
and I was like oh that's kind of weird
and then I smell burning that's the
crazy thing you can smell like well when
I landed yeah like when I landed at
Reagan today it smelled like a campfire
out there I mean it was real noticeable
but I haven't been checking it uh is did
they get an indication how it started I
don't know if you guys that's what I'm
looking at next time it was climate
change yeah it certainly was just yeah
we're driving an SUV that's why I drive
a diesel pickup so I might be yeah this
is entirely your fault I saw a video of
a helicopter laying Napalm to a bunch of
trees but I don't think that was it
that'd be crazy it's just really really
that's not going on the CNA grabbing for
straws this is air America wildfires
which indicates that they were naturally
formed well I mean I guess a human could
cause a wildfire I mean often these
things are arson but from what I've been
reading it didn't they're saying it's
normal I think it's just higher than
normal fire activity that makes sense
and so they say because humans have been
pumping so much CO2 in the atmosphere
it's causing a slightly more higher
temperature which means a little bit
drier which means more fire and you know
there is something to that we go a
little out of balance and it can send
the whole thing out out of whack so that
we do have to be careful with CO2 levels
but that doesn't mean cease production
just got to figure out how to reuse the
stuff or or continue to reuse the stuff
yeah you know I think part of this
instinct to blame this on man-made
climate change firstly it's very
convenient because you get to blame it
on your political opposition if you're
on the lap like literally everything is
the fault of conservatives you go
outside and you don't like the weather
it's like well this is some Republican
politician's fault surely it reminds me
of a quote from the one and only Thomas
Soul he said
you know good things just happen and bad
things are somebody's fault that is
exactly how we think that is just our
default pattern and so something like
the weather right is something like New
York being covered in this smog and it
traveling across the country well that
has to be somebody's fault like bad
things can't just happen or things that
bother me can't just happen I have to be
able to blame someone even in the Bible
it's the flood they said that God sent
the flood like why can't we just accept
that it could have just happened why
don't we have to blame since he sent it
I guess we have to blame God for this
one somebody had to do it I mean look I
live in Florida and they try to tell you
hurricanes are man-made I mean like the
Hurricanes never happened before the
Industrial Revolution it's bizarre we
start doing that yeah and honestly it
was not a well-marketed product people
still don't like them but someone
started making them for some reason I
like the I like when they're when they
say tornadoes it's the highest
temperature on record and it's like and
how far back do the records 270 years
look you can look back at the Ice uh
sheets they do the drilling they pull
out core samples and then they they
measure and all that stuff that I can
respect that but like there's so many
rhetorical tricks to blame anything that
can't be explained it's almost like the
Democrats are acting like Shaman coming
to the people and being like it's
because the gods are angry and you've
got to give me money and and do what I
say now yes well no that's a very
typical thing we see that throughout all
of human history a group of people who
are in power saying the reason the
weather is not favorable is because you
aren't obeying us and sacrifice your
kids exactly Human Sacrifice we need to
reduce the population size or else we're
going to get more climate change
sacrifice your children do the sun god
did they really sacrifice their kids to
affect weather I think so different yeah
I mean different groups of people the
Mayans apparently did so I guess how
many carbon credits does Baphomet take
to give us a break here how do we offset
that different groups of people
throughout history have engaged in human
sacrifice and one of the reasons
depending on the triber group was okay
hold on hold on this is actually really
interesting this is from March 11 2019
National Post ancient civilization
sacrificed more than 100 of their
children to stop bad weather say
archaeologists
it's really funny because that's
basically what Democrats are saying now
when they write these stories saying
don't have kids because climate change
is getting worse yes they're like
they're not saying to literally take
your children and sacrifice them on an
altar they're saying forgo having
children make that sacrifice
pre-sacrifice well well no it's like
sacrifice right your family
sacrifice them by just not having it no
no no it would be like sacrificing it's
not sacrificed in the sense of you take
a child and you put them on the altar
it's never never happened also and I
think you know this is multifaceted so
most people who don't have children the
people who choose not to have children
will often say things like it's because
I care so much about the climate no it's
not that's that's almost certainly not
right it's because you want to have the
Dual income no kid situation going on
most of the time and you can acknowledge
that don't don't sit there and tell me
it's because you care so much about the
climate I think that's usually not the
case but that said when you look um in
ancient Rome this is something
archaeologists have discovered just in
various periods you have like increases
in infanticide uh when people were
having more sacks and they were having
sex outside of marriage and they didn't
know what to do with the the children
and they weren't taking care of them and
you can imagine this being a trend
historically too I mean people saying I
have a child I don't want to take care
of them so I will sacrifice them in
trying to make their horrific active and
fanticide out to be something Noble and
good and so they say oh well this is
like for the sun god or this is so that
we have a better Harvest when in reality
they had that cruelty in them and wanted
to do it yeah so so right now we're in a
record low temperature for actuated
about it yesterday it was like 49
degrees at night wow and and it's crazy
it's like we're you know it's springtime
or whatever and uh no matter what
happens
the the climate change people always
have an argument as to why whatever it
is yes so they stop saying saying global
warming because it started getting we
started getting cold periods and they
said no no it's climate change and I'm
like dude it's a record low now it's a
record highlighter but no matter what
happens you keep telling me it's the
same thing exactly now I I have no
problem recognizing pollution and saying
like I don't believe the planet can hold
infinite humans that literally makes no
sense but don't come to me and tell me
no matter what happens it's perfect for
your argument look exactly I mean maybe
you could make the argument yeah there
is such a thing as too much CO2 and we
want to keep the elements in balance and
it can be bad for for life on the planet
but if you're gonna sit here and tell me
that every single thing that happens
with respect to the climate is a result
of human behavior what you have is a
circular hypothesis because it started
with first it was global cooling the
world was going to freeze then it was
global warming and then it became
climate change okay you have to build a
predictive model that tells what's good
us what's going to happen successfully
instead of just bashing us for not going
along with your cause and then blaming
whatever happens to happen on our bad
behavior because of your circular Theory
now now believe it or not we actually do
have a segue from the weather into the
culture War I kid you not now normally
moves back it's a hard segue we're going
to jump to a new story no no we got a
segue with this story from Snopes from a
few days ago did a church that Embraces
lgbtq plus people burn down after a
lightning strike was this climate change
white supremacy exactly lightning is
very white that was absolutely white
supremacy good point
Zeus is white and actually see him the
gray hair and the beard the Trident that
proves all the markings so irrefutable
as as sort of a buffer between culture
War and the fact that the air is unsafe
to breathe we we had this story and uh
was it you that brought it up Sheamus or
was it Ian oh no I brought it up I saw
that on my news feed I started laughing
I was like is this real and then it was
this guy Eric says woke lgbtq plus
Church gets struck by lightning and
burns to the ground oh my God and Snopes
did a fact check and guess what it did
get struck by lightning it did burn to
the brown it did support lgbtq issues
but they won't write true on it would it
be hilarious if they actually were
fact-checking the claim specifically
that it happened because it was a
punishment from God and they were like
fact check true we have to admit it this
is it's true this time we'll give them
that and then but this is being
objective normally you know Snopes will
be like true thing happened false mostly
false in this article it says oh okay so
it's from today actually did a church
that Embraces lgbtq plus people burn
down after a lightning strike the answer
is yes it did it quite literally did now
that's not to say God literally struck
the church down but Snopes won't even
write true here
yeah so uh they say it's not sort of an
explanation on June 6 a viral tweet with
a video of a church building fire began
to receive thousands of engagements the
caption of the Tweet read woke lgbtq
plus chariots get struck by lightning
and burns to the ground in the story
we've let out the facts they say Okay
blah blah blah they say the Tweet was
captured June 2nd the church did Embrace
uh the these issues over the past
several years so that's that's all you
really need to understand and of course
they don't want the narrative to be that
a thing like this did happen do you guys
remember when the George Floyd mural
exploded yes
I gotta tell you man I mean you know I
gotta say twice I don't know
yeah but stuff like this might happen
all the time also like right right and
like no no the question is how do you
determine whether it's something Beyond
or something just well I think you also
have to look at I mean look to be
rational for a second which is boring I
mean it looks like a pretty rural area
it might have just been the tallest
building in town with a steeple yeah
which would have logically attracted the
lightning
which is to me has been a problem for
the conservative moon for you that's a
whole other show I think that uh there
is something to be said for this right
because obviously we're sort of being
facetious about this lightning or this
mural being struck by lightning and the
church being struck by lightning I don't
know about that mural but I will say
well I'll I'll say this that was like
flat I think and I I think this specific
thing got struck by lightning as
actually a more convincing argument than
the weather is vaguely changing so we're
gonna blame X Y and Z you you actually
have a specific Target there so it makes
more sense to make the argument you have
a very complicated argument that
consistently morphs to to fit whatever
the left's political views are and then
you have does God smite
that George Floyd thing I don't know man
this is why so you'll see George Floyd
but not this church for shame Tim I
think well because buildings get struck
by lightning no the George Floyd mural
was a flat brick wall right only thing
that exploded Off the Wall was the
picture of just George Floyd and it was
like one small storm cloud floating over
and went yeah
is a sniper sniper's smiting we need to
do a survey to find if lgbtq churches
get struck by lightning more often if
they do if they do then absolutely so
anecdotally I went to Burning Man and
there's there's at the end of The
Burning Man week you there's the temple
that everyone like puts their their old
thoughts and feelings they all like
notes from dead loved ones things they
want to like let go of and grieve over
they put him in the temple and the
temple the energy at the temple when you
go to the temple is just like siphoning
up and it's just it was tough to get
near that place and I was tripping so it
could be I could be out of my mind but I
think there might be something too like
honing energy into physical objects
complete anecdotal nonsense of course
religions from time and Memorial talk
about it you know imbuing uh an idol and
things like that and cultures have
sacrificed children to the weather yep
for Millennia yep I think people are
known to have called lightning is that
like what if like it turns out that you
actually do have to sacrifice your kids
to to Malik to stop the weather from
going back but I'll tell you stranger
things stranger things are happening
around us man let's face it if these
crazy things started happening would
anybody be really that surprised at this
point
oh my God this can't happen at this
point I'm pretty sure if the ground
split a fissure emerged in DC with like
lava bubbling up and and Malik emerged
like blowing your eyes people would be
like huh
that doesn't necessarily have anything
to do with the fact that it is
Washington DC Mala could have risen
anywhere with this church lightning
strike I would believe more that it's a
directed energy weapon from like space
than it is God why but like who would do
it though as a directed uh
Massachusetts it's your target of
opportunity right right so division you
know you wanna you wanna set people on
their heels censor Massachusetts
yeah it's Putin is like we must Target
Spencer I'm gonna listen but it turns
out the church was actually like a
covert CIA yeah
once at a massage parlor or something
like that well I think we can take this
a step further the reason this church
was struck by lightning was because of
climate change which is the fault of
Republicans therefore this is a hate
crime boom I'm just gonna blame it on
Liz Warren yeah
when did this it's always a safe bet
yeah it gets struck today or yesterday
it was after the wildflowers from this
room June 2nd someone super chatted uh
John Fisher saying there's a set their
satellite footage showing all the fires
in Canada starting at the exact same
time totally not suspect
seeing this online now too people are
saying that yeah yeah I just got that
tweeted at me it could be like so
they're implying that someone has some
kind of space laser that they can use to
start fires with or like a temporal it
seems silly temporal critical mass
temporal is that the right word
temperature wise critical mass like it
hit a certain temperature and then
everything got really flammable at like
96 degrees you'd have to have like a
very very powerful laser in space to be
able to hit the Earth with that kind of
you know to start a fire but I will tell
you guys something another anecdote
about 12 years ago I was outside of
Vegas so I said Let me Take a Ride by
the that area you know Area 51 and those
entrances there's a couple little
businesses there and I'm talking to a
guy as a local maybe a hundred people
live around there and the guy was a
normal rational guy he worked in Vegas
for the casinos and all you know
contractor and I said to him joking I
said oh do you guys see UFOs he goes
Nana that's all nonsense he said but you
gotta see sometimes you'll sit out here
in these energy weapons he said it would
blow your mind some of the stuff we see
him test only because you can't avoid it
right it's just this big vast area is
and against the contrasted dark sky so
the capability is certainly there I mean
if you need you know the military hasn't
been shy about alluding to the fact that
these things exist at this point we have
space force right uh clearly we didn't
make space force a branch of the
military to do research and Horticulture
you know 18 000 you know miles up or
whatever it is how many miles up we are
so there's definitely something to that
I mean I got to believe we've got
weapons floating around up there you
know and we just said Canada set it too
good for too long we're gonna they
really have come on they've been like a
very like actually I don't know about
that is not the Canadians it's the trees
uh the trees the trees they're upset
about the CO2 the trees were saying some
naughty words and hate speaking words
yeah yeah those ants we hear about
Lockheed Martin's compact Fusion reactor
they started this program in 2010 uh is
a fusion power project at Lockheed
Martin's Skunk Works and so if they're
public about a fusion program what
aren't they public yes and how much
energy can they actually direct probably
oh dude I saw I saw a tour of a nuclear
submarine just on the news and I'm just
like okay if if they're publicly sure
what do we have we got something way
crazier yeah think about it right we
found out about the stealth fighter not
the bomber not the B2 the F-117 that
Nighthawk somewhere in like the late 80s
early 90s right that thing was
operational since 1978. we found out
about that 12 13 years later so who
knows people probably thought it was
aliens they probably did they did but
they certainly did right and the B2 so
what in the world are we deploying now
do we know about these things they're
out there line cubes I I wish that I
came plasma I wish I could remember the
exact
um I wish I could remember the exact
example he gave me but when I had Jimmy
Aiken on my show yesterday he was
talking about the fact that there was a
fighter that the stealth fighter the
government was testing and people were
seeing it and they thought it was
extraterrestrial and the government was
basically like relieved and letting
people believe that because they didn't
want people to be on to their their
capabilities oh so that's probably why
this new disclosure came out yeah right
that's also a point he made right right
when uh the United States is getting
involved in one side of a conflict and
he was also saying that um the U.S sort
of wanted the USSR to think that we were
in contact with extraterrestrials so
that they would be afraid that we had
alien Firepower which is completely
insane but apparently there's like
actual records that the the government
was was interested in this strategy and
so you see this whistleblower who's
coming out and saying
um that you know we're studying this
craft that wasn't made by humans right
at the same time that we're getting
involved in this conflict between Russia
and Ukraine you think yeah maybe one
explanation here is it's a psyop and we
want the Russians to believe that we do
have an alien craft which is crazy to uh
The Men Who Stare at Goats yes right
that's that really happened though the
United States tried to trick the
Russians into thinking that we were
trying to develop telepathy so so then
the Russians heard that they said oh my
goodness America is trying to basically
did so they actually started doing it
and then we saw they were doing it and
we actually tried to start doing it we
Psy upped ourselves into trying to
develop telepathic methods did it work
no they tried to give people heart
attacks they tried to get these psychics
together earlier Channel energy but to
give them heart attacks maybe it didn't
work and apparently it didn't work or
maybe it did work yeah I heard that they
teach CIA assets not to if they're
following someone not to stare at the
person they're following because it'll
give the person a tendency to turn
around like you know when you're being
watched kind of thing yeah that's not
and normal and apparently there are
people who have come out and said remote
viewing is real that the U.S military
worked on it and actually were able to
engage I was looking at I had a did a
bonfire a couple nights ago and I was
looking at the coals after the fire was
over and just like the way they were
moving and like all kind of glowing and
and senescence I don't know what the
right word is in essence it was like
dude I can see how ancient Shaman would
would stare into the coals and see
Visions because it like almost takes
your brain over man and you might just
see what you think you want to see but
it is that is a like a meditation oh
yeah yeah Ian keeps everybody here
honest yeah well no I mean Embers are it
is actually interesting just sort of the
the wave fire operates there's so much
Beauty in nature that I I think could be
misunderstood but that certainly like
lends itself to the the human mind
creating something more from it did you
guys uh watch the the CIA whistleblower
two days ago talk about the uh the alien
thing it's the most yeah I watched it
and it was like this guy's lying this is
obviously like the way he said he's like
I swear to God it happened like he
didn't say God he said something uh like
it just it the way he used a word that
was like uh that was made it very
apparent that he was like lying uh maybe
we can watch it or bring it up at some
point I don't know if you guys I watched
his interview like 30 seconds long I
didn't get a chance to to see it he
wasn't convincing no he's right it was
more like trust me bro yeah like I did
the I saw it trust me bro no you're not
you're not gonna get any proof he wasn't
there have been more convincing
whistleblowers the only thing that
worked in his favor I think is that his
attorney was a pretty well respected guy
he was the dodig Inspector General who
is insisting that he believes him now
again I didn't believe him either but
he's certainly not this guy's a
government employee he's not making the
kind of money that that one would make
to retain an attorney like this if the
attorney thought it was all BS so it
makes you wonder why this guy would take
on the case why this guy would put his
reputation in front of it unless he was
read in to a different program and
they're using this as a disinformation
tool to throw the bad guys off okay that
makes a lot of sense like we're about to
start deploying some crazy stealth right
or like uh energy weapon Tech over
Ukraine and they want him to think it's
alien yeah so you go to an old D or did
IG guy who probably still carries his
clearance his TS seis were reputable and
you tell them hey play ball here you
were one of us for a while help play
ball here help spread this and it serves
its purpose okay wait I found a clip
it's hard to find a lot this is only six
seconds David group believe it or not as
fan as Fantastical as that sounds
it's true and believe it or not I just
who says believe it or not when they're
trying to tell someone what happened and
believe it or not Tim it really happened
yeah
he's he's trying to convince the guy he
looks like every guy we locked up for
something who tried to convince us he
didn't do it well we were we were going
to segue from weather into culture War
issues and turn it to weather and Aliens
instead because you just can't control
where it goes so now we're gonna hard
segue back you can control the weather
you can if you sacrifice yeah or with
lasers or space silver silver iodide oh
yeah yeah not space lasers quite
literally just infrared lasers
clouds and they use uh silver iodide as
well and they've done that since the 60s
and it's really funny that if you tell
someone that the government controls the
weather the implication is that you're
crazy and it's like we I learned this in
grade school right they like showed us a
book and there are cloud seating because
it works I think they do it over Dubai
is it they made it rain yeah they do
that and they and it was public I mean
they made a media event out of it
there's no secret there yeah it
condenses all of the water vapor in two
clouds making rain come down yeah I
wanna start controlling lightning I want
to know more about their lightning
programs the problem with lightning is
that you can't measure the the the
charge the voltage whatever and so I was
reading about why we don't capture
lightning energy to use and it's like
you can't measure it so you can't store
it properly you need to know you know
volts amps or whatever the power that's
coming through to be able to accurately
but you can't do that did you guys see
the the blue Sprites above Earth's
atmosphere when lightning strikes it
like sends a blue flame out into space
like the lightning comes down and as
it's coming down a piece of blue flame
goes out and up oh dude that's great
that does look very cool you're looking
at a blue Sprite you know have you ever
just just one more thing about lightning
before we move on it next time there is
a lightning storm where you are get the
slo-mo camera out on your iPhone if you
have one and just film it's crazy to
watch that in slow motion
don't that was a howling wind did you
hear it yeah yeah whatever you do don't
run into the gay Church
Lightning's spectacular man I love it
let's uh let's jump to this story we got
from the daily signal three arrested
after antifa clashes with Armenian
parents at California school board
meeting this is uh significant regular
people are saying no over and over and
over again we've got the Bud Light
effect you've got Target and now you've
got parents showing up saying you know
we politely requested that these books
not be in our schools now we're
protesting then the far left shows up
these extremists and start attacking
parents yeah now you've got clashes this
is this is where things get crazy
because if you've got regular guy
wearing hoodie and jeans being like look
man I don't know why they gave my kid
that book and then some crackpot Fallout
extremist shows up those regular people
are not going to vote no they're not and
I'm now going to vote they're gonna the
regular people are gonna vote and and I
was going in a different direction the
uh
I'm gonna use the word the left loves
especially when they deploy their Dei
and esj initiatives they love the term
stakeholder so tpaca did a panel on
debanking because our fund experienced
it because we did some work in the
defense sector ammo et cetera et cetera
and we were debanked from a couple of
Banks and one of the words they love
they've changed uh the nomenclature for
who's invested from shareholder to
stakeholder right so the stakeholder
according to these big Banks like svb
that went under and the Really woke
Banks
um First Republic out in California they
consider the homeless guy sleeping in
the ATM Lobby a stakeholder that's right
right
but in this scenario
antifa whomever they were they have no
stake in this whatsoever no stake
whatsoever so the parents the kids the
teachers the administrators the school
board local elected officials you can
argue they're all stakeholders I hate
the stakeholder term anyway
but the radical leftists who showed up
had no stake in this they were showing
up simply to be instigators and what
they everybody's trying to make this
about Armenian Americans and this and
that no these are just parents who've
been fed up they've had enough you saw
it you know not far away from here in
Loudoun County and uh here these people
said enough's enough and I think that's
the way now I'm not trying to get
anybody's head but I think that's how
many of these parents saw it it wasn't
where a certain uh uh you know
demographic and and this is politically
ideological and we're opposed to them
because we're conservative and they're
no I think they're just basically saying
these are our kids what the hell
business do you have here and why are
you coming here to disrupt the way we
want our kids taught and the way we want
to parent and as we've seen I mean you
guys know Timmy you've been out there
and in the streets with this stuff they
instigate they instigate they instigate
and they've always gotten away with it
and this time they didn't they just had
Fed Up parents who had enough who wanted
to protect their kids and I think you're
going to see more and more of this
because people are just look you could
do a lot of things don't come after
people's kids when you you start coming
after people's kids bad things happen
yeah it makes people desperate like
create like you see the mother bear the
female bear greater than that yeah it'll
just go sight completely blood-like it's
not even bloodlust like it wants to hurt
it wants to protect that child
and it will annihilate and even if
you're well meaning you see a little cup
you want right it's just you want to pet
it and cut it if you're well meaningful
people in this movement this political
movement the trans movement or whatever
you want to call it are for them they
believe they are well-meaning right but
it doesn't matter if you're if people
find a threat towards their children so
you need to understand that people are
exciting right if you remove the Bear
Club
these are these are people who are
intentionally targeting children with
overt adult content that's right Matt
Walsh daily wire we'll get more in depth
in this after we wrap up this story did
an expose where he found this this
rubber stamping of procedures of section
procedures because these companies are
getting tons of money for it they are
not well-meaning they are selfish
egotistical violent narcissists who are
in a cult I just rewatched the music
video of will convert your children you
remember that oh yeah well can they're
your children like smiling and like and
like like yo you can't just joke and say
that out loud they're not joking I know
they said they were joking like a week
later or two weeks later after the fact
you're like I was just we were just
playing around
people you were going to convert their
children how they do it they said
they're gonna get their friends they're
going to bring me by bit Yeah you
there's nothing you can do to stop it
you can't control what your kids see
like the boys they're talking about
giving your children access to adult
content to indoctrinate them yeah
they're doing it now yeah and and so I'm
surprised it took this long for parents
to to realize and to be active and for
the record it was a San Francisco Gay
Men's Choir who has made this video
where it was like a bunch of guys
singing about how they're going to
convert your children
I mean whoa but listen it's not a new
the parents are fed up now because the
bad guys the groomers call them what you
will are getting closer physically
closer in proximity to the kids when I
left law enforcement go back to the
early mid 2000s I worked quite a bit
right before I left and then after with
the national Center for missing and
exploited children and I wish I could
unsee some of the imagery and some of
the case files I saw that I wouldn't get
into here it wouldn't be appropriate but
what I will tell you is this has been
around for a long time
NAMBLA the North American man boy love
Association they skirted laws for years
because their first amendment protected
right they said well we're simply
disseminating information on Nations
that have lacks laws for sex with kids
or uh if you want to protect kids don't
go to these nations that have child sex
tourism that's how they get around it
but if you really want to get into their
psyche there's a great book it was
written probably in the early to mid 90s
by an FBI agent the guy's name this one
the bureau actually did some good work
and wasn't a political persecution Squad
I believe the guy's name was Bob gamer
and it's called the last undercover and
it's about he's pretty much spent he was
an anomaly he pretty much spent his
entire career undercover he wasn't a guy
that did field work for a while then did
it for a little bit and came back he
just had a knack for it and this guy did
everything from biker gangs to Lakota
Nostra his last one was embedding with
NAMBLA and he embedded as a trust fund
guy who was a pedophile and the things
they would do like back when there was a
mall at Herald Square in Manhattan they
would congregate a group of these
pedophiles these men from like their
mid-30s to their 70s would go to the
mall in Herald Square on the second
floor and watch the kids come in after
school and pick their targets and this
has been going on but you couldn't we
tried we went after NAMBLA and Nick back
went after namblin the bureau and uh
Homeland Security investigations HSI is
very good at this one of the best in the
world uh we joked about Canada the RCMP
has really talented child sex crimes
investigators but these guys are smart
and the scary thing is they're often
well funded and they don't fit a profile
anybody in this room could fit the
profile anybody in a restaurant can fit
the profile it's really difficult to
tell who they are but they are proactive
and they are some of the worst Predators
you'll ever see now what they're doing
they've been so emboldened for so long
by knowing how to play the system and
knowing how to frustrate law enforcement
that they've getting close they've
gotten closer and closer and now they're
comfortable physically getting into the
schools becoming teachers becoming
administrators now
I'm not going to go off on conspiracy 10
into my Global pedophile networks and
all yeah there are definitely Global
child sex trafficking networks this is a
law enforcement established fact right
isn't Maxwell in jail because of that
she's 100 of you obviously no I'm saying
that what I'm saying is I don't think
you know Hillary Clinton's personally
abducting kids and the podesta brothers
are helping her Advance picking the kids
up and we've seen those things too I'm
not going to go down that road but there
are definitely child sex trafficking
networks around the world we know this
right in fact one of the groups that
that actually has helped are the Mexican
cartels because they know it's bad for
business right if you talk to federal
law enforcement or intelligence
Community they'll tap the cartels for
information on some of these truck
drivers because cartels don't look they
want to sell their drugs right and
they'll traffic adult women in
prostitution but they know kids are
really bad for business that's when we
send special operators down there to
start killing people if they start
abducting kids to solve the problem but
they've gotten very bold because they've
gotten away with it for so long they
haven't been prosecuted now they are in
the schools that's not conspiratorial
they're being handcuffed and pulled out
and you're not seeing the stories
because the left-wing media doesn't want
to validate what the right's been saying
but exactly but I think you're talking
about the uh the super liminal and the
issue at play now is the subliminal well
I think they go hand there's both right
hand in hand but this story is they
pretend to be activists they use cover
of media so I I referred to one
journalist as likely a pedophile because
she was covering up overt pedophilic
actions you've got this one teacher now
I think her what's her name Sarah Bonner
or something in Illinois
instructing young children on how to use
adult anonymous gay sex apps right why
would a teacher go to children and say
read this there's only one answer but I
don't see that as subliminal I see that
as overt that's over what I'm saying is
that when you get activists in the media
defending it saying it's it's you hate
gay people that is the is the subliminal
that is the manipulation right where
they are taking control of the machine I
tell you if there is no pushback and I I
don't see this becoming a reality
reality but they will try to legalize
this stuff yeah
they will but to your point Tim about
about these these journalists and all
and you see them as pedophiles
themselves you're 100 right here's
here's here's a case that that isn't a
pedophilia case but it I think it's a
good parallel I don't know if you guys
remember a lawyer named Lynn Stewart she
was a lawyer for Abdel Rahman the blind
Sheikh he was the guy behind the First
World Trade Center bombing in 93. right
when that wasn't too devastating and for
years federal law enforcement knew that
she was he was her client but they knew
she was assisting aiding abetting and
she would always stand behind her law
license and privilege well finally they
had enough and they uh you know they
knew it was the crime fraud exemption
right they knew what she was doing they
were able to get surveillance in the
federal holding facility saw that he was
giving her kites you know prison notes
she was passing information on to these
terrorists enabling his Terror Network
and she eventually was was conducted
prosecuted et cetera et cetera it's the
same thing these journalists who are
sympathetic to this are doing they're
enabling it and they should be
prosecuted as such I just looked up well
Ophelia well that that's a very very
difficult line it's one thing if there's
an active terrorist giving instruction
to a terror Network and you're acting as
a courier for the for that illegal
information and if you're giving but see
here sorry I disagree with you if you're
giving them cover by using your law
license to Shield how do we know these
journalists aren't doing the same how do
we know the journalist engages in an
illegal activity by all means prosecute
them if a journalist has a disgusting
opinion fire them and make make what
they do Unthinkable but what I'm saying
is most normal human beings most normal
human beings would not be permissive of
such heinous Behavior unless they had a
stake in it somehow right right so I
think there's probable cause there yeah
or at least Reasonable Suspicion to
start looking deeper to get to the PC to
get the warrants yeah agreed yeah yeah
uh you you made this point about people
infiltrating the public school system
and I think that's very important
because what the left in the dominant
media culture has made very clear to the
American people is that if you are
someone who wants to abuse children as
long as you're using they them pronouns
or the pronouns of the opposite sex they
will treat anyone who regards you with
suspicion as a bigoted person who
shouldn't be listened to
that's right that's right I just looked
up philia this is a lot of like word
play that they're do that people have
been doing pedophilia philia is a type
of love from Greece ancient Greece and
it's the type of love that translates as
friendship the love of friendship uh
philia it's fine but arrows hemophilia
yeah Eros is love sexual love now these
people are pederotic they're not
pedophiles they might be both but you
got to call them pederost's at the very
least like they're it's about the the
it's not about I mean it is weird for a
grown adult to be friends with a
nine-year-old kid that's not their son
but it is it's the erotic love that's
the problem you know what I had a I had
a former Federal prosecutor good guy who
did these trainings at Nick Mac who
would drum that into everybody's head
they're not pedophiles they're
betterists he would say exactly what you
just said because he wanted to draw that
distinction goes back to a lot of what
we say right in in conservative or or
libertarian media that that language
does matter don't let the left own the
narrative don't let them create new
terms he was adamant about that so you
spot him oh that's good who was that
that did that it was uh I forget the
guy's name we had a bunch of trainers I
forget his name he was an FBI agent back
when the bureau was good and then he was
a federal prosecutor I got to dig it up
for you yeah man love is not love there
are many different types of love and
that is super important let's jump to
this story we got we have a major story
from the daily wire this is crazy I my
jaw hits the floor uh hit the floor when
I saw this Matt Walsh uncover uh
undercover investigation catches trans
Health Care Providers rubber stamping
sex change surgeries basically they had
a producer call in and within 22 minutes
in a virtual appointment even after
saying they weren't dysphoric the person
wrote a letter saying they were and it's
simple there's a lot of money to be made
in rubber stamping these things and
sending them out and you are protected
politically when you make money this way
the daily wire reports some of the
nation's largest trans Healthcare
Providers are rubber stamping approvals
for a life-altering sex change
procedures and even falsely representing
health diagnoses of patients so
insurance companies will cover the
medical medical expenses daily wire
house Matt Walsh revealed in a tweet
thread Wednesday so apparently these
doctors will say explicitly if we don't
give you this diagnosis the insurance
will not cover it so you need to be
diagnosed this way and then let me let
me actually I think I have the uh the
thread here I think he explicitly brings
up that the his undercover uh producer
says that uh he's not dysphoric let me
see
he says the letter keeps capitalizing
orchiectomy is that he pronounce it
without and before it as if it's just
been copy pasted into a template Greg
followed up to learn why he had been
diagnosed with gender dysphoria plume
admitted to just use letter templates
provided by wpath he says just checking
on this to make sure this will be okay
in the letter I'm not really considering
myself dysphoric so wanted to check on
that one thing otherwise letter looks
great the doctor says the care
coordinator Hi Chelsea look at this you
get iPhone says she her hers this is
redacted a care coordinator with plume I
will page your provider on this to see
what she says I know we rewrite we write
letters based on wpath templates but I
can ask your provider if it's necessary
to have it and if not perhaps it can be
removed
later plumes nurse confirmed in order
for the surgery to be paid for the
dysphoria diagnosis would need to remain
at the same time the nurse appeared to
confuse it to why Chelsea Bussey had
requested testicle removal in the first
place
saying uh let's see so Chelsea Bussey
which is the undercover is a male
producer for Matt Walsh thanks for
getting back to me I was just saying I
don't feel this Fork right now but it's
okay to keep the letter right the nurse
says nurse practitioner oh okay well the
surgery is related to the gender
dysphoria which you which you diagnosed
with it is controlled with HRT but in
order to get the surgery to be paid for
a GCS it will need to be related to
gender dysphoria which you are diagnosed
with does that make sense or is the orki
not gender confirming
so it seems like
basically what they're uncovering
these these companies
they don't care they want the money they
want the money look I can't get my dog
on an airplane with a letter from a
doctor anymore but in 22 minutes you can
be castrated and it can be paid for by
insurance I mean this is sheer incentive
whole Industries Insanity right now it's
marketing they're marketing and look
it's the same as the vaxxas right and
they're marketing but they're protected
and this is the crazy thing they're
protected that's right Jimmy Dore had
such a great bit that I saw today he was
like when it came to Big Pharma people
would people say don't do your own
research the media comes out don't do
your own research it's like what that's
crazy we used to call doing your own
research reading yeah not to read and he
goes we would never that was an
excellent bit he said we would never
tell anyone to to to not do their own
research in any other area imagine if
you were like I think I'm gonna buy I'm
gonna go buy a new car don't look into
it
how am I supposed to know what car to
get ask the salesman he's the expert
yeah it was a great bit it's absolutely
fantastic salesman he's the experience
it's worth watching what we have with
big Pharma and these men medical
practices political protection far left
extremists saying do not look into it
and the media saying that's right if you
do something's wrong with you yep
remember when the New York Times wrote
not to think critically
I gotta tell you man if you I look if if
I don't know I don't know how to help
these people genuinely if they're like I
was told not to think critically so I
stopped so listen I mean since we were
like five years old right Nursery School
kindergarten you're told I mean it was
it was like the most ubiquitous
statement on the planet when you came to
doctors get a second opinion yeah until
we learned fauci's name then anyway if
you got a second opinion you were a
crazy conspiracy theorist you were
anti-science you didn't trust the
experts give me a break look at this is
a break this is crazy Matt Walsh post
the letter which says she reports
ongoing gender dysphoria despite the
fact that in texts the producer said I
do not have dysphoria right so this is
also something that we learned a number
of months ago when Jamie Reed who was
working at a clinic that was giving
treatment towards minors came out and
basically said that there's I'm sorry I
had a backup routine sorry I had to
correct I have it backwards that was the
earlier tweet they then asked about it
and he then said he didn't have
dysphoria so my mistake sorry continue
no no I was just saying that uh
whistleblower named Jamie Reed who was
working at the St Louis transgender
Center was talking about the kind of
rubber stamp routine that happens here
and how there are these templates and
what they do is give people sort of tips
on what they can say to the therapist to
ensure that they're going to be given
the green light to go ahead with these
procedures I went to a doctor for a
checkup a little while ago like a month
ago and uh the doctor was like how have
you been feeling like mentally I was
like oh I'm existentially I got a lot of
stress you know the world economic order
the the shifting and he's like you want
something for that yeah and I was like
do you want to like do a blood test on
me do you want a psychological like you
want to do an eval first or do you just
want to hand me some Prozac like the guy
just he was so ready to give me the the
medicine the the drugs yes and yeah the
medicine the psychoactive whatever
suppressants or whatever the hell they
are question for you guys do we know
which state uh Greg was uh chatting with
this company do we know which state this
company was located in uh I think we we
probably do let me uh the reason I ask
is is my next question is going to be
why isn't the State Attorney General
opening an immediate insurance fraud
investigation on these providers oh I
mean this is insurance fraud this is
something I want to clarify what I I was
saying with the letter the so first the
letters the the letter is posted uh let
me let me grab it from uh this here we
go so in tweet number 13 it says three
days later problems in this letter to
Chelsea busy who does not exist saying
he was experiencing gender dysphoria the
producer then responded saying no I
don't the coordinator then responded
well it has to be in there
so keeping the letter as is saying this
person has dysphoria despite the person
texting saying no that's not true that's
insurance right that's blatant insurance
fraud I mean that there's your probable
cause also potentially medical malp
these are all over the country certain
apparently this is all over the country
but but the intern for it's criminal
that's a felony I mean the fact that the
other elements of it aren't criminal is
also that's a whole statement of our
laws yeah yeah and this is something I
mentioned Jamie Reed is a whistleblower
we also had a Helena kirschner on who
was describing her experience and the
fact that she went to Planned Parenthood
and was able to get the maximum dose she
could get after a relatively brief
conversation or I think she said she
didn't even talk to a doctor I mean
they're just sharing this stuff for a
few minutes and then she got the maximum
dose of testosterone and and initially
the the person she was speaking with
wasn't even going to give her that but
then she asked for it and they just gave
it to her I mean it's it's unbelievable
and so if you had any other field of
medicine where there were this many
scandals with this many different
whistleblowers coming for forward and
saying yeah there's actually this entire
complex set up around trying to give me
the proper answers to tell to other
Physicians to get certain treatments
that they're supposed to be vetting me
for objectively we'd be having a
national dialogue about it but we're not
when we're talking about literally
amputating body parts that cannot ever
be replaced or restored once they're
removed and
mutilating children
the medical marijuana rack was a racket
they were like you've got to tell them
that you have that's fair stress or they
won't give you the medical marijuana
card so you go and you're like I have
stress and then they give you the card
and then I think in some areas right if
if you said that you had that kind of
stress and they gave you a medical card
it actually precluded you from being
able to own a gun you'd for 12 months
for 12 months you'd have to put that you
were a current drug user that stuff is
amputating there's no amputation it's
it's a license to buy marijuana which is
ridiculous I don't know much less
serious than removing cutting an arm off
or a body part off or testicles or
whatever yeah I'm very libertarian on
the weed issue I think it's I couldn't
care less couldn't care less yeah never
never came across any bad guys that were
you know trying to kill anybody but now
I'm starting to wonder completely honest
are you well I mean you've you've got
all of these uh detrimental things that
they're trying to pass on to people so I
just don't trust them oh that's a
different story but yeah if if Democrats
came out and they were like we actually
think Jello pudding's fantastic I'd be
like
that was the thing here I've said this
before
I I'm totally against the federal War on
Drugs I think if a state wants to eat
you know ban marijuana I'm totally fine
with that but I remember when I was
graduating high school about 10 years
ago this was when the massive push was
happening for weed to be legalized and
when we actually started to see it
happen and all of the arguments being
made instead of making the libertarian
argument which I don't necessarily agree
with but which I think is a better
argument and that is this might be bad
for me but let me do it there was so
much mythologizing about how this is
going to cure your cancer and it's a
miracle it's like okay like you don't
have to do that either right you don't
have to push it all the way in that
direction but I hear you
that also made me more suspicious at the
time that just all the domestic claims
about how great it was that's marketing
though yeah which look big Pharma is
just downright demonic in the way they
Market these oh yeah right I mean I mean
they're marketing you watch TV in the
middle of the day I have it on in the
background right when I'm working
every other commercial is a former
commercial for something the side
effects are it's a 45 second spot a 30
second spot the side effects and the
horrible disclaimers 29 seconds the side
effects often do what you're trying to
treat that's the point and then after
that commercial like two commercials
later it's some Law Firm it's like you
could be entitled to money right if you
took this medicine from that same
company that's now been recalled yes
wait a minute there will be one
commercial that's like are you suffering
from Acid industry indigestion see if
acidoso is right is right for you side
effects may include explosive diarrhea
and headaches then the next commercial
is are you suffering from headaches an
explosive diarrhea see if this drug is
right for you Zantac is going to kill
you you know no it's it's it's nuts I
mean it's just crazy and I think we
learned quite a bit about big Pharma the
last few years but I think I think what
they've done you know John Stossel did a
good expose on it years back where he he
made a strong argument for big form
right I guess his brother Works in that
industry and he was saying how on
average they spend about 800 this was
then about 850 million dollars to up a
drug and some don't it work others do
work but they're just not prescribed and
so he made a good argument for why
certain things cost the way they do I
don't think anyone ever foresaw what we
saw in the last couple of years I mean
you saw a farmer commercial one every 10
commercials my friends and I are brought
to you by Pfizer yeah my buddies and I
are on a text chain one's a banker for
one of the large Banks but he's very
politically like-minded and we just run
jokes all day long like have you taken
your Sky Rizzy today do you have your
relaxation and your Prevagen like it's
just not every you know it's just crazy
every other commercial it was when they
told me not to question it I was like
what in this exactly yeah don't look
into it it yep yeah trust the experts
and also them saying that they were
looking into things right when fauci was
saying he wouldn't even entertain lab
leak he won't even entertain it you
won't even think about it really
you just not thinking critically Sheamus
yeah exactly you think John do you think
that the federal prohibition on weed is
because of Pharma the Pharma industry
100 right but right now the federal
government's not Prosecuting weed the
DEA so I've got a lot of friends at DEA
they uh their policy right now I asked
one of my buddies who's an agent this
isn't some guy I know it's a guy who
lives in my neighborhood we socialize I
said so you guys hit a house you hit a
trap house and you find I don't know you
know 10 kilos of heroin you find 15
kilos of coke and five pounds of weed
what do you do with the weed he goes oh
destroy it we don't put on the charging
sheet anymore because doj it's it's not
they haven't legalized it but they're
not they've basically decriminalized it
so they're not even Prosecuting for it
it's not even going to show up yeah the
heroin will be logged the coke will be
logged but the weed just they burn it up
or whatever they do so that's like
they're doing they're doing work just
leave it ignore it like would you do you
take a okay
they seize it because it's still
technically illegal but they don't
that's it that's where begins and ends
it gets burned and they're done but they
just keep it schedule one just in case
there's somebody they want to bust well
I think you make a good point right
because DEA and FDA tend to work hand in
hand right FDA does the Civil
enforcement
um DEA comes in with the gun I mean FDA
is as uh armed agents when needed but
the DEA steps in for the bigger stuff
but think about who who
typically funds and and eventually
staffs FDA and that pipeline goes back
and forth like John McCain had with the
defense industry and his staffers right
the FDA and big Pharma trade bodies back
and forth and so
you're talking about cutting into
massive profits I've got a buddy who's a
neurologist a pain management doctor he
loves weed for certain uh chronic pain
conditions he hates prescribing opioids
he doesn't want to do it he won't do it
he'd rather give a shot uh you know
spinal uh injections Etc he just hates
it he hates what it does to people he
won't prescribe them anymore and he's
very successful doctor
he that the pressure he gets from the
farmer Reps for being pro weed and he's
not even talking about flour a lot of
times it'll be gummies or vape or
edibles and it's helping his patients
the pressure he gets is unbelievable he
tells me yeah so yes to your point and
by the way I want to make the point even
though I mentioned I'm fine with states
banning it like I don't dispute that
there could be legitimate medicinal uses
for it I don't know enough about it but
I've also heard people who are
Physicians claim that there are are good
reasons to use it uh you mentioned the
fact that it isn't generally prosecuted
and you brought up the point that they
could selectively prosecute I guess you
know if Trump starts smoking pot they'll
be banging down Hillary
doj has written policy now to not
prosecute for weed and and the sister
federal agencies uh even even Homeland
for example they you know they're not
doj they're they're their own entity but
they're just not Prosecuting the federal
prosecutors won't even bring the case is
it because they can't get a verdict or
they just don't care I mean look part of
the problem is they're starting to see
the revenue right so take take form as
profits out of it their taking back big
tax dollars to the federal government
these dispensaries they're making big
money right now if you have a medical
marijuana license in Florida which is
that whole seed the sale model
you've got a show as we sit here today
guys if you can't show 50 some odd
million liquid around 55 million liquid
ready to go you're not even going to be
considered for the license wow yeah it's
real money if you want to buy an
existing operation they're starting in
the nine figures wow yeah down in
Florida anyway because you've got it's
seed to sell right or it it was meaning
the people that grow it also the people
yeah they want you to have a holistic
ecosystem they want you to have the land
they want you to have the dispensary
it's all got to be one pipeline so they
call you know seed the sale pipeline
well I I think I think we should be
legal but I don't like it
that's it right but but again to your
point
let me do it you know not me per se but
if I I don't I don't like legislating
morality yeah there needs to be
education man yeah it's about dosage
anyone that gets sloppy stoned is not
probably not in a great state of mind
they're gonna get sloppy drunk yeah
that's way more dangerous I agree with
you on the morality thing the issue is
that Society shouldn't tolerate it
shouldn't tolerate uh immoral things and
the problem is we have a culture in
society that tolerates everything and so
we just have true immorality running
rampant and now there's no morality on
the left they have no moral framework at
all none like to take Florida right
you'll never see I shouldn't say never
but I can tell you right now you
probably won't see uh in the short term
recreationally legal weed in Florida and
it's really not a political issue it's
the hospitality industry they're big
they don't like the smell they they
think it'll turn guests off they think
if they have a real thing there are
certain areas that just stink now well
that's it and they're in their logic is
sound they're like hey look it's one of
the other reasons I mean not to Veer too
far off track that we don't get open
carry in Florida it's because the the
hospitality industry we have a lot of
European tourists guns aren't as
prevalent they're afraid of it it won't
come they'll spend their money elsewhere
so I do get that as much as this 2A
absolutist as I am but with the weed
I've spoken to a few of the hotel
ownership groups and all and they said
look we don't want to be charging 800
bucks a night in season for a room have
affluent families there a couple of kids
come there by the pool and then they
start these families start checking out
because they don't want their toddlers
smelling this and seeing it yeah you
know so it does make sense at least for
flour like oil for flowers
yeah they're fine with that they don't
if somebody's face yeah but just it's
the flower no smoking I mean no it's
better exactly what you're smoking you
can't that's right no smoking that's a
big part of it too is smoke smoking is
hard on it that's right and the cigars
do the same they don't allow cigars
either at these pool decks and all
uh sorry that I took us away from the
Matt Walsh Station it's
fine no no I
fade a good point though
um
oh my goodness oh this is that New York
Times article that Tim was right well
misinformation is information they want
you to miss don't go down there you got
to read it first yeah I know don't go
down the rabbit hole critical thinking
as we're taught to do it isn't helping
in the fight against misinformation
beautiful what a ridiculous I know just
blatantly inaccurate it is it's like
specifically saying the wrong thing
don't question it that's not how you
this is what I was saying about weed
when when they start moving to legalize
it everywhere and it's particularly in
these states that you know kill and
sterilize kids I'm kind of like I don't
know if I trust them you know what I
mean like maybe maybe it should always
be the thing on the out like On The
Fringe where it's like it's illegal but
you know people do it sometimes we
shouldn't have people in prison for it
but we shouldn't just be explicit with
recreational use I don't know man I'm
fairly libertarian so I just ultimately
here's actually I'll put it this way I'm
becoming more liberal I suppose than
libertarian in that I'm starting to feel
like
one we need to repair culture
desperately so that people aren't giving
their kids pot or encouraging
recreational use of drugs and things
like that
but we also probably do have to
legislate to some degree things that we
view to be moral
yeah well you I well that's the thing um
it's really not possible not to
legislate morality right all law has
some basis in Morality uh but when it
comes to this question of misinformation
and telling people not to do their own
research I mean this is so obviously
self-serving for the mainstream and for
the establishment you know exactly why
they're telling people this and it's an
example of things kind of coming full
circle I quoted Thomas Sowell uh on the
show earlier tonight and one thing I
remember hearing from him that really
got me thinking was he pointed out that
in the public school system today
kids are taught that it's very important
to make a difference and he also made
the point that they're not taught that
it's important to know about the thing
you're trying to make a difference about
and when he said that it resonated with
me because that was very much my
experience in public school I had many
lovely teachers but there was kind of
this prevailing ethos of go out change
the world make a difference and not much
of a conversation about how you should
also research search these things become
knowledgeable about them really have
something to say or do that's meaningful
and now it's actually come full circle
to the point where they're openly saying
like not only should you a make a
difference but B you shouldn't do any
research about the social change you
want to affect you should just listen to
us when we tell you how the system
should be rearranged and then you should
do our bidding let's talk about this
story from the Daily Mail Fox threatens
to sue Tucker Carlson for violating his
contract with the launch of his new
Twitter show that 80 million people and
Counting watched so why are they doing
this
I think they want Tucker Carlson to shut
up until after the election it makes no
sense why they would take him off the
air but then also say you can't talk
like he made a Twitter video
and they're saying you've breached your
contract why yeah because he posted a
video of himself on Twitter that's
normal social media this is what we're
just talking about with critical
thinking in the press the Press does not
want anyone breaking the narrative so
they remove Tucker from the airwaves
exactly and so we saw this with James
O'Keefe right and project Veritas coming
after him again not knowing a whole lot
about the law or the legal precedent
that's there the fact that they would
remove him from their organization and
then try to stop him from doing his
journalist at work when he's no longer
with that organization suggests to me in
my personal humble opinion that there
are issues with the journalism he's
doing because he's no longer affecting
them in any way unless that's the thing
that concerns them so similarly with
Tucker Carlson being Allison from Fox a
lot of people were making the argument
that they were only throwing him out
into the cold because of this Dominion
settlement even though Tucker didn't
really say anything about dominion and
now you have them trying to silence him
even though they don't have any more
liability there so it makes it perfectly
clear that the purpose of casting him
out wasn't like to settle a lawsuit it
was because they really didn't like what
he was saying and they're upset that
he's saying it somewhere else now yeah I
think it was both though I mean look
they they paid out almost a little over
three quarters of a billion dollars
right so they're they're super sensitive
to be in suit again at the same time one
of the things I learned you know having
worked in media as long as I did it
there is a tremendous amount of
pettiness in in the c-suite especially
when the hosts or particular hosts like
Tucker become wealthy and powerful and
beyond the reach of of that c-suite of
management they become that it's not
that they're seen as uncontrollable
because you've got to extend you know
your key employees a certain amount of
trust right you gotta let them be who
they are and they're adults and they're
responsible and Tucker never crossed
lines right he was Sensational but
that's what made him good but they get
jealous it's weird they get really
jealous when the talent becomes more
famous more powerful than them and I
think this became an ego battle so they
they say it's about uh the Dominion
lawsuit and they force them out and he
goes off on his own and they think haha
we've got him he's gonna go probably
he's a wealthy guy he's generally
wealthy now he's fine but he goes out
there he goes on Twitter and then they
start doing the math and they realize
wait a second if this guy takes even a
third of his audience with him and he
charges them a couple of bucks a month a
few bucks a month he's gonna be doubling
what we paid him while he really doesn't
need us he's not going to come back and
grovel so now it just seems to me to be
real Petty nonsense like they're just
gonna try to make his life he doesn't
need them I wonder how much of this is
we must silence certain voices sure
before 2024 or Trump wins so James
O'Keefe Veritas not only freezes him
they then sue him yup Fox News does the
exact same thing
now look maybe it's coincidental that
almost at the exact same time Veritas
suspends O'Keefe but locks him in the
company Fox suspends Tucker but keeps
him in the company and then both get
sued for trying to do their work to
continue their work it seems a little
bit odd just saying I think I think the
O'Keefe situation was different though
and I had some unique insight to this
because I'm friendly with two different
board members who are on opposite sides
of the issue and well you know the old
saying right there's two sides of the
story and the truth is somewhere in the
middle but the one thing both of them
uh uh agreed upon well when they told me
their versions and I wasn't with them
was that O'Keefe was never fired
that he was benched and that the that he
did violate the NDA and that's what they
went after him for and this was right so
they tell James he can't work and then
when he says I'm going to do my own
thing they say we're suing you know to
stop you from doing that well so that's
evil I'm with you on that but what they
had said both of them said well it was
more about the violation of the NDA and
going out there now it's his NDA well
it's but there's still a 501. yeah I
don't care no I hear you I'm the lawyers
are weird people right lawyers lawyers
look at things differently anybody at
Veritas who is in agreement with what
they're doing to James is an evil
despicable piece of garbage but Tim I'm
not arguing with you lawyers or lawyers
you know lawyers the board hired lawyers
to do this for them sure James starts
project Veritas he runs it and
everyone's behind him then they come and
subvert him benching him whatever you
want to call it shutting down his
ability to do his job so what does he do
I'll start another company now they're
suing him yo that that the only
intention perceivably is to stop James
O'Keefe from doing his work look I'll
play it and look at what they're doing
right now with Tucker there's literally
no reason to take his show off the air
and then tell him he can't post Twitter
videos I agree with you what I'm saying
is because having been through dumb
lawsuits on both sides as plaintiff and
defendant in business once you involve
attorneys things snowball out of control
so
you can't deny that Veritas is
inextricably linked to O'Keefe right
it's his brand he's the brand they're
they're one and the same the minute
lawyers got involved this thing was
going sideways same with Tucker because
in the exact same way well because look
they want to build and they've got they
know both organizations have Deep
Pockets for what reason would you
suspend someone and prohibit them from
doing work
non-competes are enforced every day I
don't I don't tend to agree with them
how enforceable they are as a matter of
law but that's just what lawyers do
because they want to rack up as much
billable as many billable hours as they
can look I picked the whole you can't
you can't pass this off on lawyers I
reject that but how if you're the board
of a 501 and your Law Firm turns around
and says project Veritas could have said
let's just let James do his thing well
here's what I'm going to agree with you
on that I think the entire thing was the
most ham-fisted moronic PR exercise I've
ever seen and Fox News all the same if
they don't want Tucker around they just
say go do your thing well they should
have told Tucker to go do his thing
because Tucker's got a bit a different
situation there because he really number
one different rules apply right I mean
one of the things that Veritas whether
it's valid or not is that there was uh
finances were mishandled now I've spoken
to some of their very big donors and
those big donors said we don't care if
O'Keefe flew on a solid gold Gulfstream
six we didn't donate X dollars to nickel
and dime him we donated for results he
got us results we don't care how he
spent the money if we gave him five
million dollars and he spent all but a
penny so on herself and got the job done
we're happy so James made the mistake of
bringing on corrupt envious scumbags to
his board who have destroyed project
Veritas look I think I think the brand
right he's the brand is him but I think
when you and now they're trying to stop
him from even doing more work look these
are evil people lesson is this I mean
you know this you run a successful
business right I've got Partners where a
small fun but we do pretty well never
bring adversary is on to a board of
directors it's the dumbest thing people
do also especially when you want to be a
proprietary entity don't
there's this weird sense of nobility
where people and look I'm gonna say it
here right now I I don't make any
apologies for having moved on from Trump
to the sadness Trump's Personnel picks
bear this out if Trump had had better
Personnel Acumen he'd be a very
successful second term president this
happens everywhere so it's not unique to
uh Veritas Fox is a different animal
because Tucker didn't pick the board but
James should have picked more wisely but
then again he's a personality he's not a
business guy yeah he should not have
started a non-profit yeah well that too
because it was he explained this how it
started was that he wanted to do some
work he needed to raise money he wasn't
thinking of it as a commercial Venture
so he said how do I raise money well if
you got to be a 501c3 so okay so I'll
file for that he was a young guy sure
for me I've had other llc's and other s
Corps and whatever so I I'm like this is
the structure that we use and there are
even arguments to be made for C corpse
over s Corps for a variety of reasons
that's right but going the nonprofit
route put them in a particularly
vulnerable vulnerable position for the
thing that he built and then these evil
people these these brain slug people
come in and destroyed project Veritas
for for what purpose other than because
they're envious and evil people end of
story James O'Keefe founded it he's the
leader of it he's the one in charge and
if the donors are happy and the work was
getting done the only reason to
interfere was because they were jealous
evil or trying to destroy Veritas
intentionally I don't think they were
trying to destroy it but I do think they
but they had no reason to destroy it
because the money was coming in and the
exposes were strong I just think then
why file a lawsuit because I think
people
people have power trips and and they
have power trips through tunnel vision
and they're and they're they become
Crusaders and they don't realize the
collateral damage that's occurring when
they become Crusaders I I don't think it
was a I I don't think it was a proactive
you know a career assassination of him
it turned into that I just think a bunch
of people said well we've got to do this
we're the board of directors we're the
austere board and we don't care who the
personality is and in the real world
that's just moronic that's not the way
things work and it's snowballed out of
control but look it bit them in the butt
at the end of the day the organization's
never going to be the same I get the
emails I don't look at them the same way
I'm with you I don't know that I'm the
same way anymore yeah he does but but
it's not just that uh so is the argument
then that these are the stupidest people
on the planet because I don't buy it
filing a lawsuit against James O'Keefe
was basically publicly declaring you are
shutting Veritas down yeah but the the
play Devil's Advocate on that if in the
Bible I didn't see him but the way it
was explained to me
in a 501 if you don't follow the rules
you could be prosecuted criminally and
so if lawyers step in if you're a board
member and you're one of the board
members that was Prolo Keith now you've
got a law firm sitting in front of you
in a good one saying look guys we
wouldn't have advised you to go down
this road but you did
and if you don't do a b and c now
and there is something well but
but here's my point once an attorney
tells you that and says to you you might
be personally liable if you don't do
these things that we're recommending how
many people are going to go out there
and say okay I'll take the personal
liability because the the actual real
alternative is to say make it above
board which would mean they go to James
O'Keefe and say I agree normal formal
termination and we're clean have a nice
day when James O'Keefe came out and said
he was terminated all they have to do is
say agreed or the idea that they're like
oh no we're gonna be prosecuted because
James is violating his NBA back up go
one I agree with you 100 here what they
should have done was call the attorneys
in before they ever took action yeah
Sato Keith at a table in a closed door
room like this and said hey guys to the
attorneys hypothetically if this were
the situation with an executive here and
we wanted to maintain the status quo and
still be compliant how could we go about
that and everybody could have shook
hands and walked out of that room
as friends yeah that's where they that's
where they screwed it that's what makes
me think it was an emotional response
that they just did it to him in public I
think it was the way it was done evil I
disagreed with greedy I played Devil's
Advocate because I've sat on boards but
the way it was done in terms of a PR
exercise was devastating the
organization unless it was on purpose
yeah I don't think it was like I said
I've spoken to both sides even the
parole key faction
on the board didn't feel it was done on
purpose they felt like you that it was a
moronically horrible execution but they
didn't feel it was malice in it how is
there anything other than a pro-oki
faction to what he started people get
very intense people get nervous if they
think they're going to be personally
sued or potentially could be prosecuted
they kind of change their perspective
you resign it doesn't matter you already
knew about it the minute the minute you
became aware of the situation your
resignation that's an insulator that's
the problem so so look if you don't blow
the whistle they can go pull the Whistle
Back
it may be nothing all I'm saying is from
Playing devil's advocate if you're an
individual look if you're a you're a
you're an a board member of a bank you
find out there's extortion you don't
report it the fact you can't just quit
and throw your hands up the fact that
they published a letter which actually
said several of the people it was
horrible several people who signed it
didn't actually experience any of this
that had ridiculous stories like James
stole a sandwich from a pregnant woman
just shows in my opinion male intent
well those were Petty examples too I
mean I had when I read that letter so
there were no real examples I called a
couple of board members I go why would
you ever publish this letter this is
moronic I said this tells people nothing
it makes you guys look horrible
it made you look I don't disagree with
you I'm just saying from from a devil's
advocate standpoint I can understand why
some people not everybody not everything
there's no there's not fortitude they
just don't a lot of people are weak
there's no Devils they don't there's no
justification no no none of that adds up
the the amount of Hoops you have to jump
through to make it make sense why they
would do this to James is is absurd The
Simple Solution is either greedy envious
people wanted to work were angry with
James O'Keefe and wanted to hurt him in
some way or they were intentionally
destroying project Veritas you know what
I think it also was I think O'Keefe's
and you know he's a brilliant guy and
the way he goes about things and and
sometimes with genius comes a bit of an
oddball personality I think he ruffled
some board feathers because he wasn't
warm and fuzzy people started to get
offended and maybe they wanted to check
them I don't think anybody ever wanted a
spiral out of control like this yes
what's the lowest level of Hell reserved
for Traders yeah betrayers and mutineers
and if you get on Twitter that's spelled
t-r-a-d-e-r-s so when when you are
brought into an organization founded by
someone who has done the hard work and
sacrificed and risked everything for it
and then you decide you're better than
them and should destroy everything they
built I just consider you being uh
worthy of the lowest level the lowest
level and also don't put don't put
lawyers and finance people on your
boards so but he must when they founded
project Veritas he had to have two
others on the board with him even from
the Inception point so yeah I don't know
if they were names or I don't know if
they were there so they may be gone the
board's been pretty new one one guy on
the board who was Pro Keef as a business
guy out of Florida that I know real well
real nice guy
um the other was an old friend of his
who wound up being adversarial with him
so it was we it was weird the whole
thing was very very weird Robert Barnes
I was listening to him in uh Viva Frey
talking about it a couple days ago and
he was saying Robert Barnes was saying
that
um Veritas wants to sue O'Keefe to make
sure that all the people that are
donated that were donating Veritas that
are now donating to OMG that they get
that money now but he's saying that like
O'Keefe brought that money to Veritas in
the first place yeah that's on it that's
not accurate you know Robert's a good
guy but his takes have been a little off
because you can't tell it don't the one
group that's impervious to any of this
are the donors they can take their
dollars but they did literally sue him
to stop him from communicating with
Veritas yeah but that but that didn't
work the donuts I mean I I look I Was
Made privy and I probably shouldn't have
been to some donor emails some of the
large ones and uh those donors were
pretty adamant we're going with him yeah
you can donate we're going with me it's
our money we don't really care what you
do we have more money than you do I said
of that uh back to what we're seeing
with Tucker Carlson I I do think whether
intentional or not we are seeing very
damaging uh efforts made that are with
an upcoming election removing trying to
silence two powerful voices that's what
I heard hunting establishment voices now
maybe you guys can confirm or deny this
I don't know but that Rupert Murdoch's
girlfriend I think it was Rupert's
girlfriend said that she told Rupert
that she thought Tucker was a prophet
and Tucker didn't like that because he
felt that is
ego I was told that story by a
former very senior Fox executive okay
so I will tell you that the person that
told me this
uh was very close to Roger Ailes and
they are
in terms of a source on this type of
thing as good as it gets you know the
other thing with Tucker could just be
profit I mean the guy is powerful he's
got reach he's going to be successful
wherever he goes the guy could stand
outside put up a video camera and stream
it he's gonna get 80 million views he's
taking revenue from Fox and the claim
that he breached his contract because he
posted a video on Twitter it's stupid so
they got him on golden handcuffs at the
moment they benched him they kept them
on contract and they're like now you
can't do anything that would compete
with what you used to do but that like
that that means you can't make an
internet video I mean that's that's how
far does this the other process how do
you define compete with what he used to
do this is one thing that you're seeing
left-wing commentators who want to dunk
on him say oh the production value isn't
very good this looks nothing like he
looked when he was on cable news I mean
well he's still getting a lot of views
right and maybe maybe there's an
argument to be made there too that the
fact that there isn't the same level of
production quality uh means it is not a
competitive product right it's just talk
I don't know how you could have a
contract that says like you're not
allowed to voice any of your opinions on
the internet if he's gonna you'd think
that he would have seen that or his
lawyers would have seen that if they
tried putting it in there and said no
you know I think they're doing you know
being more on the private Equity side of
the world now I think this one is
strictly about dollars well they know
that whenever Tucker if Tucker decides
to launch a nightly show in his old time
slot he is pulling tens of millions in
Revenue monthly from Fox they know this
so what they're doing is what big
companies do they try to scare you with
litigation because they have Deep
Pockets the problem for Fox is so does
Tucker It's a guy worth nine figures a
guy who could lay out eight figures in
legal and not feel the hit he's going to
make it back he could generate that
Revenue now foxes will fight on their
hands 80 million views on Twitter Tucker
could probably reasonably charge half a
million dollars per advertisement that's
what I said the other day you and I have
liked about somebody said what do you
think he could get for ads or live reads
I said minimum half a million Asia
in general if if if we were getting 85
million hits per video I would be going
to I would actually probably charge a
million bucks yeah and that's low that's
actually low if you're getting 80
million views you should have 100
million a year net rolling in without
have without worrying about it when you
get out of bed in the morning to be fair
that was his first episode Elon
retweeted it and so it's going to get a
ton of play I'd imagine he lands around
7 million per per episode right 7
million per episode that you're still
pulling you're still gonna if he's doing
seven million he's doubling his fox show
but after his seven billion you should
get half a million dollars
uh 243
000 followers today on Twitter wow
that's up from 40 000 yesterday so if he
had 18 000 on Monday 40 000 yesterday
240 000 today and Counting
um yeah man he's so that's 10 million a
month right so so it's half a million a
day but that's 10 million a month you do
one one hit right one one one ad a day
per shocker is going to wake up at 2 p.m
you wake up at 2PM do that you got
his producer is going to be like here's
a bunch of the stories we've gone
through he's going to read through the
news they're going to work on the script
for 40 minutes then he's going to lay
out his argument for 10 minutes and he's
gonna go back to bed no he's going to go
20 hours sleep in his pool of money and
usually I don't want to go back to bed
I'm going to swim and your point at your
point if the guy does half a million per
pop he's got 120 million a year Rolling
and they weren't spending 20 million a
year to produce his show no absent his
salary his production value can exceed
Fox let's pull out this next story
that's a very good point ladies and
gentlemen it has been a very very good
week it's been a very good past couple
of months I hope you're all very happy
as Bud Light collapses Modelo becomes
number one Target stock is crumbling and
all of those who Embrace wokeness in
these big corporations are seeing the
stock take a big hit we now have CNN CEO
Chris licked out after Trump Town Hall
he's gone they can't even host the front
runner for the GOP the corporate press
is dead Tucker Carlson gets 80 million
views on Twitter Nothing is Stopping the
uh the cultural shift the victories or
or the the strengthening the what what
we're doing have any
popular and I really I use that word
lightly have any of the popular hosts
from CNN tried to launch any kind of web
show no but they would they would take
off if they did if Don Lemon started his
own web show he'd be like making 10
million dollars I'm completely wrong I
thought you're being sarcastic
Chris Cuomo if he started his own Chris
Cuomo is on what news Nations hitting 40
000 hits yeah nothing yeah it because
this is the reality maybe it's too late
like you know it's just like
personalities they are fake
personalities no one actually watches
Tucker is an actual thought leader with
tons of fans and followers that's right
I did Don Lemon show Once in 2000
11 or 12 maybe I'm sorry like 13 or 14.
it was on uh BLM riots and we got into
somewhat of an intellectual debate about
uh I my point was you know he said well
let's bring let's bring it down he said
you know I said well look BLM is a
disjointed organization as the
leadership that's why you've got some
Maniacs going out there burning
buildings down he says well who would be
a leader I said well I don't know Oprah
this woman is a businesswoman she knows
and I got into how this woman created a
two billion dollar Empire from and lemon
was like a deer in the headlights he's
just a dim bulb he's a dumb guy he's not
an intelligent guy he could never to
Tim's point he could never pull off when
Tucker pulled off Anderson Cooper he'd
be he'd be making some good money I
think I don't think so I think he'd make
more than done than the other people
yeah probably but nowhere near Tucker
territory right no not and it depends on
her to find a good I mean I I guess I
couldn't even really put an estimate on
it yeah I I look look look Anderson
Cooper is a famous guy he can make money
Don Lemon is laughably bad however
how many people have you ever met where
they're like yo did you cut did you
catch Cooper 360 last night right right
yeah did you hear what he had to say
well every Tucker Carlson has fans and
followers Anderson Cooper does does not
he has a little bit a little bit he is a
celebrity but most people just know who
he is because of the ads and the
Billboards whereas the people who know
Tucker know him for his thoughts and his
monologues his ideas exactly his
dedicated followers too you know Cooper
and and lemon and Chris Cuomo as well
they were background fodder right people
watch airport news yeah they watched CNN
they were on in the background they knew
them they were comfortable the only
place I could see an Anderson Cooper
ending up he'd be he'd be like one of
those Discovery ID investigative guys or
like not Geo reports said give him a
show they give him a few million bucks a
year yeah he'd get a good send off from
the CIA for all his years of hard work
that's a joke calm down medium he and
Kendall
and so
Tucker Carlson when he was let go from
Fox we spent so much time speculating
over what story he broke that was the
straw that broke the camel's back
because Tucker was subversive and he
actually reported on things that people
in power didn't want the American people
to know about that's how you know he was
a good reporter that's how you know he
was genuinely good at his job rather
than just being popular because we were
having conversations about the stories
he broke the things he talked about that
no one else was willing to touch and we
couldn't even narrow down which one it
was that got him fired because there was
so much when Don Lemon got pushed out of
CNN no one was wondering oh yeah which
story do you think which subversive
story that Don Lemon broke wow do you
think was the reason those powerful
people pushed him out we were actually
arguing what unstable Outburst led to
his that's true is that why he got yes
Don Lemon when he snapped on Vivek
reportedly whatever ethnicity he is yeah
that's what he said oh yeah and he said
whatever ethnicity you are what wow he's
not the brightest bulb in the box but
I'll I'll actually disagree I'll agree
with you and disagree with you on Tucker
p people forget the intangible with
Tucker guy's been around DC a long time
he belongs to All the Right private
clubs he knows where a lot of bodies are
buried a lot I think it's as much about
the stories he hasn't yet done that's a
very as much as the stories he did and
the stories they didn't want done dude
that's a really good one I didn't even
consider that and and they know he's
shown them over the past several years
like yeah he's telling those kinds of
stories man he's like got Epstein's
Client List and he's just like that's
what I'm just like I've been waiting for
a slow news day he's like he's got
people are only talking about the
Wildfire
you made a statement earlier when you
were preempting your your ideas that uh
when when Fox let Tucker go but I think
technically they didn't let him go they
have him on a golden handcuff on
contract they do so I love Tucker and
what he's done and what he represents
but I also look at this as cut and dry
Fox owns him they're gonna sue him get a
ton of money for breach of contract and
he's gonna have to stop making content
I think he's got the kind of dollars
liquid that heat just gonna turn around
and say hell with you guys and he's
going to throw a ton of money at
attorneys he's going to fight him he's
going to jam them up one thing Fox
doesn't want to do it's not unique to
Fox every large corporation they don't
want to peel back onions in Discovery
that's the last thing they want to do
because look you gotta remember when you
when you produce discovery of things
pertinent to a lawsuit you you're pretty
much self-policed right you produce what
you and your attorneys feel is pertinent
to Discovery your attorney is officer of
the court is trusted that you're
producing what you're supposed to
produce well Tucker knows a lot more
about the interim imaginations of fox
than Dominion does the last thing Fox
wands is for Tucker in Discovery the
compelled discovery on some things that
should have been produced a Dominion but
weren't and have dominion reopen another
matter wow so you think that Tucker will
threaten to take it to court and then
they'll drop the case I think they'll
ignore them he'll ignore them he'll just
hire attorneys I don't think he'll even
hire an attorney well I think he has to
right because if they sue him well
I imagine what they'll do is they'll
send the lawsuit with intent with a
letter of intent to file claims or
whatever to engage yeah they'll send a
sample complaint like a mock complaint
then that's right not yet filed and
here's what we're gonna do if you don't
stop and then he hires a lawyer or he
might even still just ignore it and say
file it in court because he just
represents himself no no because they're
not gonna because the moment they do he
can say okay I agree Discovery time baby
because it's not his his computer is
being opened up it's theirs oh it's
theirs look they're gonna they're gonna
ask him for Discovery but his is really
Limited in scope right if they're going
to be ambiguous about why they let him
go or they severed ties or they benched
him he can turn around and play dumb say
I have no idea let's open everything yep
that's the last thing they want to do do
you think they want I mean you know the
head of PR at Fox has a reputation for
being a notoriously evil woman
I don't know what's their name because I
mean she's in PR right there's a reason
you get good at convincing people that
someone with a bad reputation has a good
one
they want are her texts and emails to be
produced in Discovery especially the
internal stuff so it would be pretty
brutal I think I think he's got them
he's got them in a rough spot so would
they release him from his contract then
or they just let it I mean it depends on
how the attorneys look listen he's gonna
claim they owe him money they're gonna
claim he owes them money and at the end
of the day yeah or they might just watch
it out he'll say just leave me alone and
let me go and they'll say we're not
going to give you a dime and everybody
away maybe I think it's more likely that
he wins something he probably will yeah
because because everybody else has oh
yeah this golden handcuffs thing is is
going to be viewed very negatively in my
opinion if it does ever go to court and
they know that that Tucker was
contracted to produce a show to host a
show they then decided he will not do
that so now they either let him go or
they pay up and so he's saying if you if
the if if we have an agreement where
it's like I'll pay you X in exchange for
you to come on the show and then I tell
you you can never come on again and then
you say well then I'm going to leave I
said no you can't do that either like I
can't do that like that's ridiculous the
agreement is that you are hosting the
show now they may have something in
these contracts because they're robust
contracts but I really doubt that
there's going to be a judge who's like
well no Tucker you're not allowed to
work right now it's more likely going to
be like this makes no sense there should
be a settlement for for separation right
right in which case Tucker will likely
say you've got to pay me X so
I've been I've been in these media
contracts before and people have asked
me like oh what if you know you leave or
like what if they they don't want you
around I'm like they got to pay out
their remainder of the contract that's
the purpose of the contract it
guarantees I get X dollars for this time
period if at any point they want to
break that they got to pay me out
I I assume what they're trying to do is
say we didn't actually fire Tucker they
did and Tucker would argue they fired me
in breach of the contract so they have
to pay me out and I'm leaving as opposed
to if he chose to leave then they would
just wouldn't pay him out and then they
may actually say you're on the hook for
yeah they want to claw back right some
some of the uh income we paid you for
three years right and if you leave they
might say he owes us the remainder of
those years you know one of the things
that leads me to believe
I agree with him and think that fox the
last thing they want is just to go to
litigation is they're not slamming them
in the Press they haven't they haven't
leaked anything on them they haven't
dropped nasty releases on him they're
being really tepid in the way they
approach them they're tiptoeing around
him part of that's obviously they don't
want to lose the remaining viewers of
his that they've kept but uh I it's an
unusual way to go about it when you're
going you know he's a Grizzly right you
typically take a kill shot when you go
bear hunting like that yes and not doing
that if he had violated the contract
that would have been the first sentence
out of them out of their mouths yeah
yeah
all right well let's go to super chats
if you haven't already my friends would
you kindly smash that like button
subscribe to this channel share the
share with your friends and head over to
timcast.com become a member and you will
get access to our uncensored members
only after show and you can even call in
sign up at the 25 per month level or if
you've been a member for us for at least
six months you can submit questions and
be one of our callers for now we will uh
read your super chat's belly flop says
Reagan legalized ads for kids eventually
90s kids rule adult suck era trained
Millennials into low quality Rebels
franchised activism now beliefs are
mostly based on what people are against
yeah I remember that as a kid in the 90s
this whole like hate your parents man
parents are dorky they don't know but my
parents were super cool and I was like
ah this is all it is propaganda of your
parents I guess because they love people
that are good to you do you remember on
The Simpsons buy me bone store Mark out
of hell no it's like go tell your
parents
essay federally says Tim your monologues
deserve 70 million views I seriously
think you and others are being throttled
I remember writing b-school essays about
how little impact net neutrality would
have and wanted to smack myself Ajit Pai
was a was a Sly bad guy
um well if you like the videos I produce
share them but yeah we're all being
throttled you know however I I do
periodically get messages from people
and they're like oh your your video was
suggested to me and I recently got hit
up by a high profile individual who said
that my videos were being suggested to
him so I'm like oh that's good news
right I don't see any of your stuff I
don't get them suggested I rarely see
you in my feet that's that's believable
every time I ever see a clip from the
show I declare not interested sometimes
if I'm feeling really spicy I'll hit
report
I'm just going to start putting
Community notes on them for the hell of
it now as I gotta report this one we saw
it was under timings no I really I don't
see your stuff so you're definitely on
Twitter I don't ever see anything you
promote rarely I I would say 20 tweets
of yours I may see one or two on Twitter
in my feed I do I do get uh your stuff
or our stuff I guess recommended to me
on Twitter we're gonna start putting all
of uh all of our shows on Twitter like
many other people starting to do now I
think I think the issue is Tucker kind
of hit it out of the ballpark and then
we're all jealous and I'm I was watching
that and I was looking at and I was like
I want 80 million views I want to be on
Twitter yeah Matt Walsh too I want 80
million views didn't to be on Twitter
also yeah come on what the heck why
don't I get those why don't I get it so
I was thinking actually I I think it's
reasonable to assume that if if I were
to put up my 20 minute Tim cast news
segments probably get a couple hundred
thousand hits per video absolutely a lot
more if I rally a lot more shares I
imagine the retention would be slightly
lower yeah but there is still a path
monetization in that if if you know if
we're selling Casper coffee in these
videos and we're getting 100
000 you know hits on each of these clips
and we convince 10 people to buy a bag
it is worth posting them on Twitter also
your Twitter Subs subscriptions are you
guys in you're doing Twitter
subscriptions that's a lucrative model
that I've just I've signed up for it
I've seen them they've started yeah
YouTube also has a very interesting
infrastructure for keeping people
watching I mean the way Twitter
functions is you're constantly scrolling
through it incentivizes you to look at
something very briefly then keep
scrolling you'll get something briefly
so I mean keeping someone invested for a
10 to 20 to you know 30 to an hour long
even video I think it's could very well
require like a restructuring of the
interface and the way it looks yeah you
want as many well not as many but you
want all the buttons you need on the
full screen model from the UI that's for
sure so like about what Twitter needs
right now is a skip ahead 15 second
rewind 15 second uh button on there but
other than that it's looking svelte like
just like you know when you're on
YouTube and you scroll you only see that
video in the comments on that video and
then off to the side there's other
recommendations like on Twitter you just
always have the option to scroll to
something else all right what do we got
I'm not your buddy guy says most of the
fires in Canada have been arson
hmm is that true
remember when they uh when there were
those far leftists that were starting
fires there was like a crazy guy who was
like throwing fire bombs into brush yeah
and then the media was like it's not
happening like there's a video of a guy
what are you talking about they're
mostly peaceful this is yeah
Mark heseltine says Orange Sky bad
I mean literally yes it's it's not good
what do we got here
John
Sarah sanguinous is that what it is the
this is only news because on the East
Coast yearly thing on the west coast
bubkus well yes it's because half of the
US population is in Eastern Time
and then everyone else is spread out
throughout the various deserts and
cornfields this is the truth
all right are those deserts and corn
fields are pretty awesome especially the
corn fields cornfields are based yeah
man feels super based looking watching
corn from above when the wind's whipping
it around is cool looks like Silk I will
say though not a fan of the whole let's
make everything out of corn thing like
everything every single thing we make
there's some guy trying to figure out
how we can make it of corn instead
because of corn no I know but it's just
very bizarre because you're like hey
normally it would cost me a hundred
dollars to buy this raw material and
corn would cost 200 because but they've
paid for the corn so it's free so I'd
rather just try and figure out how to
make corn glass we're gonna make cars
out of corn we're like we're 50 years
from your family being made of corn corn
hop everything
to make that joke for like 48 hours and
I'm gonna make it again when it is
better oh that was good PornHub well you
see that that was foreign the corn Emoji
is the is what they say for porn when
they're trying to avoid sensors and
stuff on different platforms can someone
make Corn Hub and it was like a bunch of
corn videos I'm looking it up I don't
want it sounds like chicken City dude
it's like a corn version of chicken soup
a live stream of course watching corn a
bunch of videos of just different
cornfields and people harvesting corn
talking about corn oh my gosh team
Zeppelin says Sheamus my 64 year old
wife thinks you're attractive should I
start thinking AI uh what do you mean
well I'm not sure well you know that's
very sweet if you're it's very sweet of
your wife start thinking AI is that what
he said yeah I'm not sure like putting
your face on his bodies don't I think
we're really delving too deep into this
yeah I don't think that's right I'm
uncomfortable yeah Jeremiah dobler says
global warming is a religious belief
they Cherry the Cherry harvest in
Washington state will be two weeks
delayed this year the longest delay in
history because the spring was too cold
Farmers know the truth yeah man just
look up on the internet are we still in
an ice age if you want to search it for
yourself yes we are we are coming out of
an Ice Age we're in an interglacial
period right now um that's why it's
warming up the L the ice is melting on
purpose because we're leaving the ice
age or have you considered that
inventing the internal combustion engine
was man's original sin it was I just
want to say Obama's setback interglacial
relations for years
says I'd love to try some cast brew
coffee but my order got lost DHL says
they delivered it they didn't they
direct me to you guys you guys direct me
to DHL end result no coffee for me
um I I'm sorry to hear it man the only
thing I can really say is if DHL says
they delivered it but they didn't then
it really is on DHL uh but let me write
down that order number and see what we
can do the other thing is
look we have a lot of people who email
us with well I'll I'll just we'll we'll
look into it that was nice Super Chat
because you could have used that money
to buy another order but instead you
brought it to our attention that was
very cool
let me uh let me write this down here
cast Brew
but uh yeah so the challenge for us is
if we uh if we take a package of coffee
we give it to the shipping guy and they
like say oh we got it and then they
report it's been delivered
we've already handed it off you know
it's gone it's gone shipping so like we
don't have it like we don't like there's
no circumstance in which we get an order
for coffee and then we like Chuck it
into a waste bin and just claim that it
went out yeah like all the coffee gets
loaded up into a thing given you sign up
to shipping and then I don't know
whatever they do with it
but I will look into it I wrote I wrote
your order number down sorry to hear it
buddy we'll see what we can do
maybe we'll we'll just uh send you out a
bag we'll have to look into what the
order was and everything
foresight says a butterfly flapping its
wings can cause a hurricane on the other
side of the world I propose a mission to
find and kill that butterfly yeah I
think I think that's also like either
Pro or anti-butter five propaganda I
don't know that one butterfly that's
chaos theory
um I like it
pinochet's helicopter tour says that
church is five minutes away from me was
obliterated
I just might I like that username yeah
well
what is this Tarzan jungle Kung Fu says
bootleg fire in Oregon was bad almost
half mile Acres the holiday Farm fire
was near me everything looked like Blade
Runner 2045 deep red orange air quality
so bad most places shut down stay safe
yeah my uh my sinus has been bad yeah
yeah I drank his mortgage amount of
water you know mine usually are bad but
they've been great lately I think things
are finally turning around for me
doesn't possibly go wrong yeah you guys
you guys are having a sinuses maybe I
was just built for this for this weird
Smoky weather built different that's
tough that's a fireman it's a difficult
thing to figure out it's very cleansing
this might be like a new trend like a
new spot it's like a wildfires go into
an unventilated full of smoke toxic
smoke room therapy have you done rape
they shoot the tobacco smoke up into the
nose and no blow it out is that a thing
I mean I've definitely had tobacco smoke
go up my nose but I've never that's
intentional I live in South Florida you
can find bored Housewives to pay 500
bucks a pop to stand in a room of toxic
smoke if you Market it properly Trump
all right Bobcat says you're going
straight to space lasers Tim you need to
look up the World War II bat bomb it did
more damage in Japan than the A-bomb I
read about that like was it literally
bats like they released a whole bunch of
bats yeah and the bats had uh I think
they had like incendiary like little
little pieces of flame on them some kind
like little some little like lit uh like
fuse I guess
it's true the bomb consisted of a
bomb-shaped casing with over a thousand
compartments each containing a
hibernating Mexican free-tailed bat with
a small timed incendiary bomb attached
that is some Looney Tunes stuff right
there wow that is ridiculous highly
coyote level exactly they literally
packed bats yeah yeah into a bomb hey
they sent balloons at us so we had to
get them back somehow yeah they did yeah
and those balloons were flying for a
while too yeah it's kind of crazy it's
like it actually did a lot of damage
because they just lit everything on fire
because that Japan at that point was all
made out of like wood and paper
essentially so I guess if like you're
yeah I guess if your enemies
civilization is built out of wooden
paper you could just send flaming bats
at them I don't think they're using this
anymore though I hope not let's see I
mean firstly Peter you you could like
this is how backwards things are you
could bomb civilians with something like
this and then Peter would be upset about
the bats yeah yeah I was feeling that is
that easier to just drop a regular bomb
that's time consuming to insert the
little device they were going for
collateral first you have to sing a
lullaby to the bats
Kelly says an all-woman firefighter crew
lost control of a prescribed burn in
Banff Canada causing a 70-acre forest
fire what are the odds is that what
happened recently or was that Canada is
that some time ago yeah that's up in the
mountains well I don't know if you know
this but like Alberta the the point of
having a fire department isn't so it can
really fires it so you can make everyone
feel sick because they get to be a
firefighter British Columbia in British
Columbia British Columbia
they were a female for the most part
yeah a mostly female
villainous V says Tim have you heard
about Italy making June family pride
month celebrating families and
protecting the kids I did hear something
on Twitter
well there you go
doing something
damage controlling says we'll boycott
companies for targeting children but
won't delete the social media that
actively rots your brain as they solicit
and promote Active Child abusers if you
still have Instagram after today you are
the problem I completely disagree these
are the social spaces where we are
trying to win the culture War if there
were a bunch of creepos in the city
center you wouldn't be like quick
everyone flee the city center there's
bad people there you'd be like quick
let's go to the city center and stop
these creepos so we want to be in these
spaces to dominate the conversations and
not let them get access to kids
however for in uh for as for Instagram
we should all demand Instagram do
something and stop you guys heard about
this right they're they're actively
promoting these algorithmic uh these
hashtags for trafficking that's crazy
cam girl as soon as Tim and Company
please stop with his Advanced weapons
garbage your position is we know about
ax so they must have extra secret Ultra
weapons we don't and your position is
stupid you're better than that except
Ian we love the ones yeah but I think
you're wrong the U.S would not
declassify nuclear submarines without
contingencies that makes literally no
sense it doesn't mean that what they
actually have are more powerful but
they're certainly different so if
they're coming out and they're saying
this is the inside of our nuclear
submarine they're either lying or they
have something totally different and
also they're not going to give the enemy
access to information pretending how to
right subvert our weaponry and not only
that we have a history of the military
admitting that they disclose classified
Technologies when the next generation or
at least implying that they disclose
classes
yes or 71 71 refers to YouTube spy plane
Lockheed Skunk Works right then the
SR-71 and the F-117 Stealth the B2 so
they've always disclosed the classified
Technologies when the next Generation
but those are operational those
literally existed for decades before we
knew they existed yeah like we said
earlier I think the stealth fighter the
F-117 went operational in the late 70s
we found out about it in the late 80s
early 90s I think we first found out
about that when we hit Noriega in 89
with those and it was operational about
11 12 years prior
yeah I tend to say like what if what
kind of weapons do we have you know I
like to pose it as a question rather
than be like we definitely have these
Advanced weapons that I don't know
anything about like I'm not gonna you
know yeah but I will question
Triton 54 says CO2 is an inert gas we
literally use it to put out fires
yes
well all right that's badass Stevi says
don't forget Northrop Grumman publicly
announced a plane that was not completed
yet over a year ago and still has not
flown yet how many questions
and the likelihood the U.S military has
weapons that we don't know about is like
100 I hope they do I don't want the bad
guys our enemies to know all the stuff
we have I hope we have you know
multi-generational classified programs
either operational or in development
CDE says you guys should sell chocolate
covered coffee beans tried some at a
farmer's market and it was surprisingly
good I don't even like coffee that much
oh they're incredible yes we will work
on that the next thing that we have
coming for Casper obviously is the
coffees the decaf the new Blends we'll
be launching the the Sheamus potato
blend I'm kidding I don't know what it's
going to be it's gonna be some kind of
blend we're also going to be looking on
the casper.com we're going to have
various uh Pro we're gonna have a
protein powder I think and an MCT and
we're going to do a specialty MCT
protein mix harder to make but uh we'll
have that it'll be in small batch
because we have to actually like
formulate the protein substances like
you get you get protein and then you put
it in the thing like you know what I
mean like the MCT has to be like
balanced what is absolutely delicious if
you like coffee beans or chocolate
covered coffee beans is coffee bean and
an almond one-on-one just eat them at
the same time taste them together like a
regular coffee bean yeah just straight
Coffee Bean and an almond because it
kind of cuts the bitterness the Almond
does man what a flavor
we have grapes everywhere I mentioned
this yesterday yeah yeah in a few months
it's going to be Bonkers there's going
to be tens of thousands of grapes just
all over the place on the property
you've got yeah that's awesome wild wild
grapes Frost grapes I was watching about
how to make mead I don't know if you can
make mead out of uh that's honey why
yeah that's honey and uh they were like
raspberry meat or something some kind of
yeah the black raspberries are starting
to ripen so this morning I saw a black
raspberry finally I've been watching at
this big one it finally turned black and
then I was like yeah but it's still too
early none of the other ones are ripe
and then when I came back a few hours
later it had fallen off and so I'm like
oh bummer lost it but uh but there were
a couple others try to tried a few
they're amazing and then we have wine
berries coming in a month we like it's
really funny for people who don't live
out in the rural rural areas when we
have people come from cities they were
like did you plant all of these things
and I'm like no this is just literally
what happens every year right there's
there's pawpaw there's walnuts there's
apple trees there's cherry trees we got
two black cherry trees we have
honeysuckle we have wheat just randomly
growing everywhere you can eat it yeah
it's just Foods out of the ground
look I've got property in the midwest I
won't even say where because in one spot
the sorrel mushrooms grow and they're
ridiculously expensive oh wow and this
property is on a river and it just
happens to be the right condition and
got a patch like this big and they just
you sell it abundant
get them away you go Grill them you can
do pretty much anything with them
they're awesome oh wow all right what do
we got B Walsh says the air pollution
from the wildfires is just a giant
orange wave showing support for Trump
yeah that's what I was thinking you knew
that was coming finally got the red one
that's the psyop equate orange with bad
rush rush says Jay sock is doing a
command-wide 18-minute workout and 1.8
mile run to honor the suffrage of 18
years of don't ask don't tell I can
provide verification of this if you want
not mandatory but quote mandatory
you ever see those bits where they're
like do you think we should end women's
suffrage and they're like yeah yeah and
they're like okay
and then they make him sign a petition
so much suffraging
Republicans just do that why don't
Republicans just like introduce a bill
saying like it's time to end women's
suffrage and then like the Democrats are
big oh that's so nice of them women
shouldn't suffer it's like yeah yeah
suffrage is suffering Here sign the
paper
same thing we're giving you this one
Shane Knox says here in Florida we have
controlled Burns regularly no wildfires
to speak of that's true we do them in
the Everglades you see them from where I
live they yeah because I live right
almost on the ocean a mile away but the
sugar feels the cane feels they burn
them every day something's burning out
there they just let it kind of turn to
black ash and then re-mulch the fields
and stuff yep yep yep and they really
never spread out of control it's true
sevi Rose says critical thinking isn't
helping in the fight against
misinformation they're calling you
stupid and it's not well veiled that's
right yep
pom pyro KJ says many separate videos of
helicopters dropping fire in multiple
places in Canada we shouldn't dismiss
questions that should be asked
especially when motives exist just
because it could be considered a
conspiracy theory that's the video I was
talking about when I saw the helicopter
looked like it was shooting Napalm down
into the trees below maybe they were
trying to do a controlled burn and burn
a perimeter around yeah they burn a fire
line they burn a fire line so this fire
that they can control and they dig and
then that fire stops it'll well that not
that one but that the premise is to stop
the spreading fire
yeah it's crazy the uh we have wheat
growing everywhere and it just dies and
then turns brittle and dry and you gotta
get rid of it that's kindling yeah man
that's gonna go up one spark yep it is
kind of funny how wheat like grows and
then just dies I think it's kind of
hilarious it lives for like a month or
two yeah poor week it's tired but it's
good food yeah it just gets tired of it
all so exhausted with lice what's the
point are we still here just to suffer
I don't want to be every night I feel my
arm I don't want to be a weedy
live in a box monk in training says
regarding the project Veritas board
Power Trip Rabbi Israel salenter once
said man has the potential to see Great
Lengths but a small coin blinds his
vision oh very smart yeah
good line
James will will a Wills says Sheamus as
one who is an expert at missing the boat
I beg you do not let last night's Sail
Out of the harbor
what that means
oh my goodness it was it was it was
really entertaining to listen you guys
talk it was a fun conversation and then
they they stayed up here for like two
hours afterwards I left we we did after
the after show we cup we kept talking
yeah
you uh you guys were singing here for
like another two hours no it's probably
like an hour after the after show and
then two hours about an hour I'll say
it's an hour so about two hours or two
hours
all right you guys I can say whatever
you want I'll just keep saying until you
agree okay Jacob Hawk says if the
Whistleblower was a psyop why wouldn't
it be all over Legacy Media I paid
attention because they didn't cover it
deep State runs deep are we talking
about the alien whistleblower or the by
The Whistleblower yeah anymore
completely Astro turfed Facebook
whistleblower oh yeah you were expected
to believe yeah it was real that's right
she's gone obviously put up they're just
like what needs to happen is the
government needs more control here it
was something ridiculous like that oh
here's a good one Jerome Morrow says Tim
please shout out arrested preacher
Damien Atkins give send go campaign
Damien Atkins huh
I am pulling that up
what is this uh is this the the current
one Damien Atkins arrested after holding
a sign with seven biblical words on it
at a pride event yep yeah if you guys
Google search Damien uh wait this is
Damon Atkins is it Damon probably Damon
yeah just Damon Atkins if you Google
search that you can find uh Damon
d-a-m-o-n Atkins if you want to support
that that that's shocking I mean that
they arrested that guy we can't stand
for that this guy's got to win he's got
a sue he's got to win as much as he can
standing on this on a public sidewalk
with a sign and they arrested him that's
nuts I mean he's not with a group I mean
there's there's some people there but
it's not like he's marching through the
streets obstructing anything doing
anything violent it's not arrested I'm
trying to find a picture of him uh
DuckDuckGo isn't showing it to me
oh oh oh of course B2 The Rock Says as a
Forester the Wildfire issue is far more
neurons nuanced than just climate change
there have been many policy changes in
politics that have led us here completed
my 20th pack test today to fight fire
again this season oh it's awesome nice
man
Paul taskelo says Tim any plans to head
to Las Vegas for the World Series of
Poker this year or next year if you love
poker playing a World Series of Poker
event will make you feel like a football
player in the Super Bowl hit me up for
poker coaching uh no
we we perhaps will go to Vegas for like
a big MMA fight if we organize something
like that
we'll see uh that's that's the only
thing we really ever talked about Yeah
Tim taught me how to play poker and I
just I just destroyed him and everyone
else at the poker table and it was
beautiful experience seems the opposite
of what happened we went in there I was
like Rain Man except for the part where
he's good at things well so there were
they were basically how I've been
described my whole life there were
several hands where Sheamus
kept calling the bats and then would
flip over Ace King on a board where
there's no Ace King and like someone's
got a straight that never happened no
the you
you once no actually several times no no
no no you flip over race King I'm like
bro there's no like what are you betting
on what are you talking about
I had an Ace and queen and I had a pair
I had a queen and there was a queen on
the board no that was top pair you had
said that was a good bet yeah but you
beat me that's what I'm saying how could
I have predicted that my Ace Queen was
going to be beat by whatever you had I
was like literally couldn't it literally
could happen but I had a good hate bro
four or five I had a good hand and
betting was the right choice no because
I literally beat you in the hand before
that and then you got all your money
back okay Sheamus this is sad okay
because you're you're literally
explaining why you don't know you're
talking about that's also fairy I have
no idea so let me explain to everybody
who might know what poker is so it's
actually kind of a kind of sad story for
Sheamus how can you say this because I
always have a good bet I had seven three
suited and I was like I don't know I
think I was in uh the cut off and for uh
the board the Flop comes with like Queen
five six and so I'm like oh I have a gut
shot you know I could get the straight
but yeah so Sheamus does have a queen
with top kicker so that was a that was
good but I raised you and then the turn
comes the four four five six on the
board and I raised you I've seen you
raise when you have bad hands I've seen
you raise when you know you have a bad
hand you're like I'm just gonna keep
raising because I can't give you poker
lessons live on the show right exactly
if I show you the bluff I'm
intentionally making you think when I'm
strong I'm weak when I'm weak I'm strong
so when I completed the straight and
then raised you and you were like well
I've got a Queens I must be good and you
gave me all your money it's true it was
really funny because I got my left goes
seven three what are you doing in that
hand I was like bro I was bluffing and
then I hit the five six and got the gut
shots oh those are the best you can take
all of someone's uh stack in those
situations very disguised well it was
funny well to be also like we were
sitting at the poker table it's like I
don't know if I want to play in Tim's
like look I'll buy you in the hand and
so you just got the money back yeah it
didn't even matter I was like all right
fine I was gonna have to give it back to
you anyway but but simply when you're
looking at the board and you think like
I have a queen so I have Ace queen as a
queen of the board I must be winning if
someone else is putting money in they
think they're winning too yeah I know
for sure so if you just had I also know
that I I also know that you like to live
on the edge so I was like this might be
but that's not true you just think it is
because I don't show you my cards unless
I want you to think that I'm bluffing
okay so the one time I beat you with a
bluff I flip over my cards and then you
go damn he's bluffing me all the time
well now I know then you call me all the
way down when I have a straight and I
take your money from you yeah that's
true Sheamus but it was fun he was he
was hanging out everyone was very happy
he was there yeah they're very excited
at the table I mean but to be fair you
pretty much ended up getting all of my
money that you gave me I don't think
those other people really got much of it
no they didn't Clint was there too it
was a lot of fun Russell
Raymond g Stanley Jr says Tim always
bullying Sheamus yeah it wasn't fair but
we're trying Sheamus needs to learn how
to play so he can be on poker with the
boys that's true I literally so the
thing is like when we go there I'll play
Blackjack I like Blackjack um I've never
really played poker before and so to do
this show I'm really gonna have to play
poker is really fun if you like to
destroy people
all right guys I'm in yeah well so we we
play Fridays just for fun for like you
know like little 20 bucks or whatever
but the whole time we're joking and
saying extremely crude and offensive
things that are the funniest things
you'll ever hear that we can't repeat oh
well I can't do that then but we're like
the part I don't like if we tone down
some of the uh the the if we tone down
some of the uh hate speech by a notch or
two then it'll be totally
why can't we just do the eight speech
thing without playing poker
never take all the fun out of it but
it's like it's it's like we're we're the
the the the jokes everyone are saying
they're just unafraid and so I'm like we
definitely need Sheamus on this show so
you've got you got to be able to play
the game no it's true look it's it's uh
it was fun it was definitely fun
yeah I'll have to I'll have to get some
more practice in my problem first time
ever really playing actually with poker
it's great is that I get so competitive
that I want to debase the other person's
will to live in the game like get the
question their own sanity like I will
make them think that they're a loser in
re like fully just to win their money
like very dark and dirty when I play
that game with the blackjack dealer and
it's crazy too because some places allow
really bad table etiquette really where
like it's brutal man I I won't I won't
play again like dude look these are low
stakes games one two yeah it's a couple
hundred bucks to buy in you leave with a
couple hundred bucks you don't really
lose a lot you might make a little bit
someone might lose a little bit no one's
like this is not 10 grand at the table
this is the low stakes but there are
some people who are just so nasty and
they know they can win if they if they
trigger you if they tilt you so they'll
say stuff like if if you if if you play
right but still lose they will Target
you and say things that don't cross the
line to get them kicked out but will
piss you off because they want you
they'll talk about your family they'll
talk about oh my gosh World Series of
Poker Wilds I don't know about an actual
tournament stuff they might tell you to
stop yeah all right everybody would you
kindly smash the like button subscribe
to this channel share the show with your
friends become a member at timcast.com
go to timcast.com click join us the
uncensored show will be starting in a
few minutes and you don't want to miss
it you can follow the show at timcastirl
you can follow me at timcast John you
want to shout anything out not just five
if you want to uh learn more just follow
me on Twitter at John cardillo I'm
getting beat up I'm pretty good these
days by my old friends in Trump World
because I moved over to the status but
uh it's been kind of amusing by the way
right on I want to mention that dirty
dog Luke in chat says that Sheamus is a
bum that deliberately loses the Tim so
he doesn't get kicked out it's just
untrue I mean at the one on the one hand
that does help me say face a poker uh
but my name is Seamus Coughlin I make
cartoons we're releasing a cartoon
tomorrow you guys are really going to
enjoy it we had a lot of fun putting it
together
um I had it took a lot to write like all
Saturday I was sitting there just trying
to figure out more jokes to add to get
it ready for y'all so I think you guys
are gonna like it go over to Freedom
tunes and subscribe and if you want to
help support us in what we're doing and
the team that's that's helping me get
all this stuff together
and animating it go to freedomtunes.com
and become a member you'll get an extra
cartoon each week and you you will be
supporting uh artists who are creating
content that isn't woke that's anti-woke
that's conservative thank you I'm Ian
Crossland follow me at Ian cross and I'm
the best that ever was it just continues
to get better I'm gonna work on my trump
um impersonation and then you guys are
going to be blown away when you hear how
good it is the best in person Sheamus
and I have a skit we're gonna work oh
yeah I'm excited for this John always
great to see you man yeah man it's
always it's always fun to be here with
you guys it's always a great time super
fun dude thanks for the data uh and I
also have Mr Duprey on my right yep
surge.com here uh I will cut my beard
because you guys seem to care about what
I look like even though I'm on the
screen for like five seconds an episode
but anyways uh search.com on Twitter see
you guys later we will see you all over
at timcast.com thanks for hanging out